[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
yes
we did it y'all we did it welcome
welcome to the 3d live stream
happy saturday to y'all um thank you for
your patience i really appreciate you
guys hanging in with us while we're
taking care of some technical
difficulties you know how it is
sometimes there's a lot a lot of ones
and zeroes flying around and uh
you know
there was there was like there was a
couple more ones and zeros fighting
around this morning so oh good there
might be a little camera glitch going on
but whatever this isn't about me today
this is about all of the artists who won
the infinite journeys challenge so we're
having on the winners
i'm going to interview them all we're
going to talk about their workflows
we're going to talk about how they went
about creating their art we're going to
talk about
the their breakdowns we're doing a bunch
of cg breakdowns today with all the
winners from the infinite journeys 3d
community challenge so it's going to be
sweet we're gonna have four of the five
on today for you um
and very very soon here we're gonna get
started with tyler uh you're gonna
recognize his art as soon as i play it
on screen it's gonna be amazing um
what else yeah so after we do the
interviews i'm basically going to do a
little weekly challenge review and
announce the five winners of the weekly
challenge so that'll be exciting and i'm
just excited to get into it we got some
really incredible artists using
different programs cinema 4d 3ds max and
blender all with different perspectives
and different techniques getting to the
same incredible result
so i'm very very excited to hop in with
you guys now before we begin this is the
last thing here um i gotta throw it to
our sponsor today micro center
we'll be back in a second
micro center is the sponsor of today's
live stream if you're looking for an
affordable workstation computer parts
electronics networking tools laptops
monitors you name it then micro center
has got you covered now i know that pc
part prices are still on the high end so
when you're looking for the best deals
micro center is running them all the
time click the link in the description
and see what you can find and if you're
an artist who needs an affordable
workstation micro center has
knowledgeable staff over the phone and
in store who can help you find the best
rig for your personal budget now
personally i prefer going in store for
bigger purchases i enjoy talking to the
staff about my purchase and holding the
item in my hands and if you feel the
same then micro center has an in-store
offer for new customers where they're
giving you a free 128 gigabyte flash
drive and a 128 gigabyte micro sd card
no purchase necessary limited time offer
valid in store only limit one per
customer so the next time you are in a
pinch and need computer parts
accessories and more then go to micro
center for the best deals click that
link in the description and gear up for
your very next project
yo
tyler what's up dude
what's up clint
and everybody how are you doing
how are you doing heck yeah dude
um congratulations man uh i think
fourth place yeah fourth place in the
infinite journeys
challenge very very awesome let's see if
i can't take care of this last frame
here we got a little last frame coming
off here
that's alex alex is next this is this is
tyler time
let's see here bam
bam
bam your art is incredible dude it is
like
i love
that style so
much man what was like i have a ton of
questions for you we're basically we're
going to take for the audience here
we're going to take about 30 minutes
with these with each artist so i want to
do like 10 minutes just to get to know
you and hop into the breakdown here as
well as um take it to the audience too
and ask a little bit of um
a little bit of q a good yeah let's do
it
so dude first first off i gotta ask like
how did you get into 3d what was like do
you do this for a job or is this just
like a side hobby or or what's the story
here man
yeah i mean it's it's both and
everything um yeah like i i run a small
business i'm out of south dakota um in
the united states and uh yeah i mostly
do
informational motion graphics so i'm
connected with schools and businesses
and doing uh like glorified powerpoint
kind of stuff you know
and uh but yeah like my um my school
background is on 3d production animation
art for video games
and uh so i'm kind of just a little
studio doing doing all the above i guess
amazing so
i mean what got you into 3d in the first
place
uh nintendo
yeah
i've always been a fan of video games
and that's what got me to school like
there was this article in nintendo power
magazine saying like oh you can go learn
art at this school and uh called the
digipen institute of technology in
washington
and uh so i i was like oh man that's the
coolest thing in the world and they had
summer workshops for high schoolers and
so i uh went there and just kind of got
my feet wet and learned that i love
doing the art side of things and it kind
of went from there
dude i think i'm very similar man video
games are such a huge inspiration for me
and i think a lot of the audience too a
lot of people watching here
um and 3d artists in general it's like
video games is probably like the number
one thing um because we're diving into
these worlds and we want to create them
ourselves
and what you created here is just
absolutely incredible man
thank you thank you
so
inspiration wise
um
what are some of your favorite video
games that inspired this art here
oh man um
i guess i would say that this
this one was inspired by video games so
much um there was more art that i found
like on art station that inspired this
one yeah um
but uh just a general like
anime kind of stuff i guess is pretty
um
enthusiastic for me um and then i guess
stuff like avatar you'll see some
examples as i walk through it of um some
reference that i pulled from for this
but
yeah i mean i don't know video games
just mention anything from the
good old late 90s and early 2000s and
that's my my generation
absolutely dude absolutely i definitely
see some like breath of the wild along
with some avatar in this like those are
two of my favorite things ever so
i think you yeah nailing it
that's awesome yeah i'll tie back into
some of that stuff too as we go through
the reference if we get time because
there's a lot of yeah legend of zelda
stuff that was inspiration for me on
this
yeah absolutely all right so let me see
here i know i just switched over to my
desktop let me work a couple things
around here i want to be able to
see what you're showing me as well as
the chat alright so
um soto i know you're in the background
here i'm see if i can watch your stream
so i can see
tyler's work here
yes yes
yeah
um so
tyler um
oh goodness alex you're next buddy
you're next i know you're slipping in i
know you're eager
but we're gonna get you we're gonna get
you don't you worry alex
um
so
yeah what was what was your process
with this piece of art here how does
like the people who are watching who are
are dabbling in 3d or who want to get
into 3d or maybe like just like myself
who i'm i do a different style i'm more
of like a photo real kind of guy how
would i go about
starting a scene like this what was your
process like
yeah um can you see my my screen i've
got my making of video pulled up here um
yeah let's switch over
so
visible
all right good to go perfect
yeah so i mean
i mean for people who are getting
started the thing is just to
do it you know like play around with
stuff like you can learn things anywhere
i mean youtube is full of great examples
of people who want to teach
and
um you know just like diving into stuff
especially with things like blender is
just free it has the capability of like
the highest caliber 3d programs now
um
it's like just to start making stuff you
know
absolutely the information is out there
um yeah i think in the past it was
absolutely necessary to go to school
to learn how to do this um
especially because like the programs are
very expensive but nowadays yeah like
you said like blender is it's a free
program you can hop in there's a lot of
free and it's very accessible 3d is very
very accessible now and
like more than ever now more than ever
so very much so i think that's good
advice to just hop in and do it for sure
so where did you start where did you
start on this thing like how did you how
did you begin
um so yeah the starting point was um
like going through different ideas and
uh
um yeah like the starting point was
completely different like i wanted to my
initial idea was like making a spaceship
pilot and it's going to be this old guy
and he's looking out his window and he
sees this younger pilot doing like some
maneuvers that bring him back to his
glory days oh when he was a an ace pilot
and um
i started playing around with that idea
i kind of pitched it to people around me
and they were just kind of like
okay
like um there was no excitement in it
okay and so um i mentioned it to my wife
and she's like you always do stuff like
that like you should do something
colorful and like foreign and i was like
okay that's totally new
and so um
i started looking around to see some
like color inspiration
and uh let's see i'll drag this forward
here and so i found this uh painting on
art station and it just kind of the
colors
were kind of captivating um and
especially since i just watched a video
on youtube where someone was pointing
out how some of the best films use a two
like a very simple two color
um
i guess scheme i guess for their
uh for their films yeah and so i thought
this really played into that with like
everything in the background is yellow
or orange and everything in the
foreground is you know it does get dark
but it's a purples greens um cool colors
yeah and so i thought that's something
that kind of could stand out um
or it stood out to me as something just
kind of fun that i could practice and
play around with um and so yeah then i
just kept looking up inspiration like
for movement um i can play that
and so i found that shot of some guys
just like running along holding some
flares or something
and i thought maybe i could play
something like that
so you're starting with right you're
starting with reference and you're
starting with certain artists certain
color palettes and you're like trying to
you're essentially gathering those
things together to be inspired and have
that lead the direction of your piece of
art here is that right
yes very much and that's my personal
style especially because i'm more of a
technical artist
um i'm not an idea person at all and so
it's like if you come to me at the
beginning of the day and it's like all
right dream something big
i'll just be sitting there with my
hammer and you know like my tools to
build it i'm like i don't know what to
do like i don't really have a vision for
stuff
um and so this kind of stuff like starts
to get a vision and seeing people do it
before me and making more of a collage
of it rather than just like an idea
straight from my head um
that makes it a little bit more grounded
for me to believe in the idea
yeah absolutely very fair um i think as
starting out as an artist so i've always
enjoyed drawing you know and
i it when i was learning and i'll always
be learning but like when i first
started out drawing um
it was easiest for me to draw other
people's art and yeah
you know or or like right now i'm
learning how to play the piano and it's
easiest for me to like play other
people's music
and i think with 3d artists too when you
first start out it's fun to
recreate other people's work it's a
great way to learn and grow when you're
when you're like first starting out
and then i think like once we can get to
the point where we can start doing our
own custom stuff that's when it gets
really really nice and you kind of break
through that layer of oh i'm just
copying other artists work to
now i'm actually creating original
art here and i love that
you are looking at references from other
artists you're not recreating those
pieces but you're using it as
inspiration to create your own original
piece and that's that's absolutely
wonderful
so once you have your reference where do
you go from there how do you start
sculpting the scene
yeah so um then it just comes to the
drawing and this is i mean
basically what i've just told you that's
everything that was in my mind when i
started this
this drawing here and so it's very loose
like not much is thought out um i'll
kind of speed it up a little bit here so
we don't run out of time but um
essentially i took that and then tried
to integrate those colors back in
and maybe those flares that those people
were holding maybe those are like
magical fairies or creatures that are
kind of flying around yeah um
and then at that point then they still
don't actually think through everything
um and so that's like what is the girl
actually wearing what kind of like
travel outfit do they have um what sort
of equipment does he have uh like what
is this guy over here like in this
drawing he's kind of got this bicycle
helmet thing and i mean that's all just
like
um
oh what's the term like a flowing design
from my previous um
you know like my previous sketch here
was i didn't think about what that shape
was it was just sort of an upside-down
basket on top of his head yeah and so
now i think it through like okay well
what could that kind of be and it's like
well maybe some sort of foreign
helmet hat kind of thing like i don't
know um totally looks like a mushroom
helmet to me
yes yeah like a little bit of uh like
captain toad i guess
i like if toad grew up
and like yeah
kind of just got like a new vibe you
know um i grew the beard and like
uh went on a long adventure this is
definitely the vibe here so you you put
this together in photoshop or what yeah
this is just painting with my um my
tablet and photoshop goodness that
that's incredible i'm like dude i wish
my concepts could come close
to looking like this dude mine are just
chicken scratch
this is great but you don't you don't
need a lot i mean it's like this is this
is more than i need it's just note
taking basically is you know like what
do i want things to look like where do i
want them to be what do i want the
symbols to look like it's just answering
all those questions and trying to come
up with a good answer for everything
yeah fair fair um
cause like
even though my concepts look
like butt
in the beginning
it's okay because at least i know where
it's going it's basically a way
the concept in in my experience is a way
for it to guide us
through the project with some sort of
clear direction um yep absolutely
so you're figuring out all the all of
like the design here all the shapes of
the clothing and whatnot um you're
trying to get it what as close to
final i guess ish as possible or
how much it changes from here to the end
yeah
right i actually don't have any standard
for like what i'm doing here this is
just to keep me from making mistakes as
i move forward um this way it's like i
work it out in my head like i know that
what i'm doing
will make sense you know eventually
um and i know it can come together onto
the screen in this composition so that i
know it's at least a bar that i can hit
eventually yes um and whether i can or
not uh is always remains to be seen well
you definitely did this time dude
because i mean thank you thank you i
appreciate that so much
um
so should we just kind of keep moving
through it here yeah yeah let's do it
so here's some uh so at this point i
kind of decided to go with a like a
stylized cartoon style because that i
thought that worked really nice you can
see this um aladdin and jasmine like
that color pattern matches very closely
with what i was trying to go for yeah um
and then some stuff from avatar i
thought that like face style is cool and
um not overly detailed like the shading
on this is just like a line um
and i did that because i thought that's
all i could
honestly that's all i thought i had the
skill to accomplish within the time
frame
um i didn't want to try to do something
like super detailed super realistic with
tons of players and stuff so so smart
man i
yeah i did the opposite and i paid the
price
um i mean it's hard but it's so fun
getting into the details on like
realistic stuff like i don't blame you
for that that's that's fun too
and you lose a bit of that when you do
stylize stuff i think but
i don't know it's a very fresh vibe like
that's why i love your art so much it's
a very very very fresh feeling and
i think it's it's so needed when
so many people are
doing the same thing and copying
the copies
um when you see something like this come
to life it's just it's so fresh so okay
i keep getting i like i'm just amped
about the art all right so where are we
at now it looks like you're doing a
blockout or are you um yeah this is
where i start to put things in 3d and
make sure that in 3d space my concept
will work because sometimes you can
cheat perspective and stuff in ways that
hit actually falls apart when you make
it in 3d
um download some characters these are
pre-rigged miximo characters
and i did that so that i you know i can
keep all the skin weights and i can
adjust the model but i can always like
transfer those skinning weights back on
so things like the shoulders and like
all right when you say skin weights
yeah i barely know what skin weights are
and i know there's probably people in
chat who don't know what skin weights
are what are skin weights
yeah so that's um so when you animate
something you have like basically this
like
rig underneath everything that's
controlling everything it's like a
skeleton and so you've got like your
bones and stuff and then um the actual
3d mesh is made to deform along those
same animation guidelines
and so
when you're setting up your character it
looks like this where you just have a
t-pose or something where your
characters are standing there
and then you have to define this
basically like a puppeteering rig
underneath it that tells it where to
bend how to bend um all the different
like things it can do
and so then you have to go through and
you have to tell it how to deform like
where those joints are like what part of
the forearm is linked to the forearm you
know bone in the skeleton
and you got to go through the whole
thing like head to toe shoulders and
stuff and things like shoulders are
especially hard because there's so much
like precise deformation you can't just
like have it be a tube kind of like the
elbows like if it's a little bit of a
bendy tube you can kind of get away with
it
but shoulders you've got the neck that
has to kind of stay in place
like the chest has to kind of stay in
place but also kind of be affected by it
um there's just so many different like
dynamic parts that
uh can go wrong and it's just like it
throws me for a loop every time so i try
to like start with a finished thing that
looks good and then modify it
got you got you okay um so um last last
bit here on
on weight painting is that what you're
talking about weight painting yes yep
okay so
i i messed with that a little bit on the
last two challenges i did um okay and
basically like you would see a bunch of
colors on the body like right here in
your screen it's a gray yeah gray uh
little clay material here but when
you're painting weights you would see
all the colors so like the arm might be
red completely red um or maybe just the
bicep is red and then like the forearm
is green and the hand is blue or
something and if you go to the bicep
which is red
and the shoulder is red whatever the
bicep does the shoulder will also do
which is not correct right
yeah i wish i had a good example to show
that but yeah like the entire like
clavicle and neck can like rotate up and
out along with while the arms going down
so like if you're there's so many things
if your painting isn't right you're
going to be seeing these weird like
janky deformations like the left arm is
going to control the right hip and it's
like oh crap that doesn't work that's a
painstaking i hate i honestly hate that
oh man me too
but that's why i just uh take shortcuts
absolutely okay so from here you got
your character
um you have your block out which is very
important for uh for getting the actual
you know seeing if the composition works
well with maybe a little bit of light
from there
where are you at
more concepting uh this is just to
solidify some things making sure my
concept works over the t-pose of the
models because that's how i actually
built them you know um
and then drawing out some background
like set dressing stuff just making sure
i've got some cool things and these are
these are actually kind of fun um
the like all these leather props
um they're based on like fruit and
vegetables and like gourds and stuff
um
they're like the designs are not
original at all like they're just
straight up stolen from vegetables and
stuff like i don't know like this thing
down here is uh it's just i don't know
some kind of squash that i found that
looked like that so i was like well i'll
make it leather and add some straps and
that'll be my bag
wait
wait so you you
you baste these bags on actual fruits
and vegetables
yeah like this like over here this kind
of football looking thing that has some
kind of weird
um
like plant maybe or something like that
uh this guy's pretty obvious it was some
sort of globe
fruit with like a big stem
and so and this was all to save time uh
so normally i would think things through
a little bit more than that but for this
one it's like we were so fast trying to
get this done in a month
um and plus like these background props
weren't that interesting to me so i was
just like i wanted to find a solution i
could get interesting shapes really fast
and so i just called it good it was like
here we go and they turned out to be
super cool dude that is insane i've like
i would have never thought to base my
baskets on fruit i would have just
googled baskets and started doing low
poly baskets like
that's that's why it feels like really
fresh to me
because you used it you referenced fresh
fruit nice yeah
that's so cool i love that wow
um
okay so you're concepting your baskets
you're concepting the clothes
how do you
what are you so you're using 3ds max is
that right
yes and you're modeling all in 3ds max
um
yeah yeah this was all 3ds max um
well
maybe i did some zbrush too but like it
was all effectively in max yeah
okay it looks really nice dude it's
absolutely fantastic so where are we at
now what what is what are we looking at
um yes i'm just kind of going to the
frames where i was working in max um
but like here's an example of how bad
things look like working on stylized
stuff is scary because you're working
with a model that looks like this and
it's just like woof that is terrifying
so then i had to like constantly go
paint over it just enough to kind of be
like okay like i'm not totally off my
rock here this will work
um
and this is the first time you've done
this style
[Music]
um
[Music]
yeah yeah it actually is incredible
there's so much that i had uh
and i'm gonna skip ahead a little bit
because the fun stuff comes in the
materials and rendering stuff yeah go
for it go for it we have i think i think
like 10 more minutes here we can get
through the breakdown and then we'll
take it to audience q a
okay cool um so yeah this uh this is
like an example of like what the girl
looked like before she had any outlines
or like painted details on her and so
you can see like you've got this um
there's only two colors to each material
so there's like a brighter pink and like
a darker pink yeah um and so the way
that i did that was actually um one of
the things that i saw as i was watching
tutorials on how to do like toon shaders
and stuff
is um people would use an actual light
source
and it would just be like a harsh shadow
like just a line across the face or
across the body
and it just doesn't look like a cartoon
it looks like fake 3d cartoon yeah um
and it was just hard to deal with that
and i stumbled across this as a solution
this is actually
controlled by ambient occlusion and what
that is is it's a special map that um
tells the computer like where
uh like gaps and like crevices and like
corners of things are
and so i have an example here of a
of something that kind of uses the
principle so this top left one is just
your typical ambient occlusion so it's
like in the little gaps here you've got
black and it gets kind of shaded in the
in the holes and stuff and then outside
it's white so it gives it a very
realistic like universally lit
uh look to it
and so what this little gradient here is
is it just goes from black to white so
shadows are black light is white yeah
um we can mess with that to get a little
more stylization where we say
okay everything is black up until right
here and then everything is white beyond
that and what we get is just like the
very very
deep
crevices get that black treatment but
everything else is lit or with white and
you can actually adjust where that
transition zone happens to get different
stylization
and so
um basically i did that with my
my model here where i found that
transition point that looked nice and uh
basically picked a shadow color and a
light color
and that's how i did the lighting for
everything in my in my scene
or that's how i did the the material
lighting
and so it's so good
thank you and no like texture painting
no you know like all that hard stuff
that would have taken a lot of time it's
like you just get that automatically
built in
for this
and so yeah so then at that point then i
did go into substance painter um to do
like the detail texturing um you know a
lot of little patterns and different
material zones and stuff
um
so then we get to something like this
where it's actually looking nice but
everything also everything has that like
a light color and a dark color and the
ambient occlusion like how close it gets
to corners and cracks and crevices is
what controls that brightness value
that's beautiful that's such a cool way
to do it wow so simple it's so and so
effective can you talk about the uh
like the sunlight method that you used
yeah okay so that's coming up here um
oh boy that this this is like trauma
here this is like a depression zone
where i was trying to figure out what
was in the background
um oh there's more cool stuff here but
yeah so like the actual for the
rendering lighting
um
so you can see like it's got that
ambient occlusion like just for the you
know corner shadows but for the actual
scene lighting um i did a render pass uh
using redshift in 3d studio max
um where everything is just kind of that
dark like kind of purpley you know cool
color theme shadow it's like the ambient
light it there's it's it's like the
light from just the sky minus
the the sun essentially you turn the sun
off basically right yeah yep and so then
i uh i did a pass that's basically
everything's lit by the sun
um so like what would that look like so
everything's bright it's full you know
local color and stuff
and so i
um then i did an actual like lighting
pass where it's like i get
um a mask to say like these white zones
are where i'm going to use that sun
color and then wherever it's black it's
going to use the shadow color and so
that gave me total control over those
color zones so if i like because i knew
in post when i'm putting this all
together there's gonna be times where i
want to um
like bump up my lights a little bit
brighter or maybe darken the shadows and
i wanted to play with how blue i went
with the environment like i kind of
wanted to start with like super
saturated and then tone it back to maybe
make it
realistic and so i wanted to have
control over all those different layers
in photoshop or after effects however i
was compositing this
and so
basically this let me do that
so here it's like this is controlling
that light pass
and then i blend in the shadow
and then it kind of gives it a nice rim
lit effect but i also have control over
everything too so um
oops uh if we go to the the like light
pass here these um like scroll cases and
water bottle things yeah
those could not get hit by light in
order to work nicely the way that it's
lighting his face and her face
um those lights just physically it would
be impossible to see these and so i just
threw a light down here just totally
cheated it and i did that with a lot of
places in here where it's like something
wasn't
getting hit so i couldn't see it yeah
and so i just threw in a light and i had
total control without worrying about
ruining other stuff in the scene it's
all isolated that's some good artistry
man that's the stuff that is like the
secret sauce where
it's okay it's not
realistic but it looks way better um
and
no i think being able to do that knowing
that you can do that and that you should
do that is huge because i think lighting
is such a huge part of
making something look incredible when it
comes to 3d art and even movies too like
you can really tell a poorly lit movie
from
you know uh oh man
an incredibly lit movie yeah
um
and it's the same for community too
yeah it just it's what makes the stars
stand out from the the everyday things
um so
i want to get to some
q and a
uh business here so let me um yeah let
me pull up the chat really
quick here
um
give me a shake
let's see yeah if anybody wants to see
more of this stuff it's all um available
on my youtube channel so you can find it
um
so if you guys have any questions
go ahead and add punisher me here in the
chat and let's
let's ask some questions while i pull up
the chat here
if i can remember how to use
youtube
here we go
we got 748 people in the chat today
let's pop this chat on out
about time
what's up chat
how are y'all doing who do we got in the
house today
zarek yo what is up
master wu asked how long did it take to
render
tyler how long was that oh render times
um i think that was about 20 hours total
dude that's so that's super doable
that's great
what's written on the notepad what what
do you got on the notepad there
notepad um which what this one here the
on the right yeah no no the oh i like
the actual thing yeah yeah
yeah so that was um kind of what i was
talking about that that legend of zelda
stuff so
um
i gotta i'll try to make this fast so i
was looking at what to do for the
background um couldn't come up with an
ideas went through like a week of
depression just like hating myself for
not thinking of anything i called a
friend who works at blizzard as a
concept artist and he talked me through
some stuff as far as like look into
mythology like try to find ideas that
already have captivated people
and
adapt some of those things and so i
looked up like arabian mythology and i
found this idea of this rock which you
know as you if you've played legend of
zelda link's awakening you know the
rock's feather and so that just
connected to my childhood
and uh thought yeah that's awesome like
i love the idea of this bird that's like
as big as a mountain that can take away
your elephants if you're not careful
um
and so i went with that um it came
you know it was an awesome idea fit with
the mood that i wanted for my my piece
and then i realized like feathers and
dynamic stuff it's like way too much
work
and so i simplified it into a turtle
and so
um kind of as a joke just like to poke
it myself for like obviously that was a
very lazy interpretation of this amazing
mythology with so much like life behind
it and so i imagine this guy was a like
a researcher or something he's off in
this foreign world he's there to find
this huge bird the rock
and he sees this like turtle flying and
he's like okay so he writes like rock
the great bird looks more like a turtle
to me
so he's kind of confused and i imagine
he was kind of angry at me as an artist
for ruining his expectations i love that
easter egg dude that's incredible
something you'd never see it but it's
just for me to
laugh at myself i guess
so
uh your background here this is just a
personal question how did you do the
clouds actually those that was a
question from the chat i saw that in the
chat how are you doing your clouds
um clouds are easier than you'd think uh
i just straight up painted them um in
photoshop and then brought them as
layers into after effects and put like a
turbulent displace on them dude and you
can basically make that boiling effect
on the layers
so you your background is a hundred
percent
minus the manta rays and the turtle and
yes
it's 100
2d
even the scrolling
rocks in the four
like the mid ground those are 2d wipes
yep all those are just 2d like blurred
drawings dang dude you i cannot believe
your
your freaking workflow on this is
i'm so like jealous is the wrong word
it's inspiring man it's inspiring dude
it's like this means so much coming from
someone like you oh man dude
you crushed it like you just
knocked it out of the park
and every step of the way it seemed like
was the most efficient way to do it the
mo the maximum amount of output with the
minimum amount of input oh thank you i
had to i mean there's no way i could get
something like this done that that i
thought did justice to
i mean when you look at some of these
cartoon references i mean i'm looking at
disney and whoever makes avatar i don't
know but it's like those are amazing
just like top of the line shows like
they're stylized but they're stylized so
well and i just didn't want to like
embarrass myself you know like comparing
to that kind of stuff and with the other
competitors like everyone here
oh man there's just so much talent in
this competition like i just
it was
i was doing my best because i was very
overwhelmed
yeah
yeah
you killed it man you killed it where
can people find
um your art where where's the best place
for people to like check yeah we got
your youtube channel pinned in the live
chat right now thank you ronan
appreciate that but where else
yeah thank you um
right now i don't have much of a social
media presence um i'm i'm looking to
develop some of that but honestly like
youtube is my place where i post
anything
that i think i'm i'm kind of proud of um
cool but right now i've really got like
i've got like this metroid fan animation
thing on there that was kind of fun but
this summer and like over the next few
years i'm looking to do more like
kind of video game themed
animation stuff and starting a little
bit more of that journey so
dude i apologize yeah i don't i don't
have much to like track me on things
other than my like professional work
which isn't interesting to just check
out oh no it's cool dude uh youtube is
easy just the one and done just go to
his youtube it's pinned in the chat
right now um the link doesn't work
question mark link doesn't work um
what is your youtube channel what's the
name of your youtube channel
i think it's just tyler gibbons art
okay
tyler gibbons art uh ronin maybe if you
wanna if you wanna try and grab
grab a fresh link or something we can
pin it up tyler gibbons and i'll put all
this stuff by the way guys in the uh in
the description of this video once we
get through all of the artists today
i'll update it and whatnot um but yeah
check out tyler gibbons art let's see
visual you got one let's see if this
works let's pin it
all right pinned in the chat thanks
visual appreciate you man um
sotomonte now i know you y'all can't
hear sodomonte but he's whispering the
good word in my ear how are we doing on
time are we are we ready is uh is alex
ready or do you want to do a couple more
questions soto how are you doing
all right sweet sweet sweet sweet all
right it looks like we're ready to go um
for the next one um
my goodness tyler thank you so much man
i really really appreciate you please
keep doing this style i love it people
love it um people want to see a movie
thank you like this people want to see
more like this um yeah that'd be awesome
let's make it happen
absolutely
absolutely man um thank you for your
time i really appreciate you brother um
and uh
we'll definitely be in touch man go
check out tyler's youtube channel it's
pinned up in the chat
uh looks like the link's working now
and give them some love guys tyler thank
you so much man i will see you very soon
and keep up the good stuff yeah awesome
thank you clint thank you everybody
yeah peace out
who what
alex
whoa i'm here
alex you're here live you're live oh my
gosh you're you're live
how's it going
it's great we got through we got through
an amazing piece with with uh with tyler
and i'm excited to break down it was
incredible
tyler's stuff is inspiring his his
technical abilities are
man yeah his workflow for that's
incredible
yeah is the right word absolutely man
absolutely so
first off thank you
for being available for this i really
appreciate you man um
congratulations
on uh third place on your third place
win with this piece here i know this was
ian hubert's favorite
piece um he absolutely loved so much
yeah yeah um
and i mean we all we all love the piece
i love
the fact that um
goodness
now my phone is going hold on my phone
sorry
my dang phone is popping off i got it
sorry i cut out a little bit oh no
all right can you hear me at all or no
ah the pains y'all the pains
all right stream give me a second okay
um let me hang up and
and switch back out
uh yeah there's a can hear me though
right
you hear me
alex
hello my man
soto you hear me huh
all right alex you should be able to
hear me then
yeah i can hear you all right brother
sweet
okay is it working again yeah yeah hold
on let me queue it back up guys there's
like 10 there's like 10 things going on
i got like freaking three screens and
like
juggling let me get the chat back up
hold on
like which thing do i mute which
no you're good you're good
it's just sometimes my phone when it
disconnects from my phone
and it reconnects it loses me on discord
anyway
um
so
what i love about your piece of art here
is the fact that
this whole thing works
like dude
you built this out so that literally
everything
is perfect everything works the pedals
crank this gear shaft that scrolls the
tarp
in the background and like when he goes
into hyper speed the strings go up and
like pull the cardboard tube
which is duct taped and like
this is absolutely incredible the
foresight on this um
now before we get into the art i know
because i got a lot of questions on the
heart let me just get a little
background on yourself so do you do 3d
full-time or is it just a hobby
yes i do it full-time um so i'm
freelance
um i'm from chicago a lot of the work
that i do is at stern pinball actually i
do like those lcd screens on pinball
machines now so i'm making like just
whatever visuals are needed for whatever
game we're working on which is just a
crazy variety of random art
which for me is great because i get like
just
like
it can be anything coming my way in
terms of art which gives me a really
broad like
it's sometimes i have rigging tasks
modeling tasks animation tests so i kind
of learn a little bit of everything
that's great so you're very well-rounded
the job that you have
um
kind of challenges you in multiple ways
that that keeps your your skill level up
not just on one specific task but kind
of a wide variety of 3d in general is
that correct
yeah yeah more or less and then i i'm
pretty flexible like i have a lot of
free time to do like challenges and
stuff like this and i love doing
character art that's like always been my
like the direction of my passion in 3d
art so
like my free time is consumed with a lot
of uh like character art specific work
so um
that's like a lot of where my specialty
is i would say
okay got you man got you um for me it's
the exact opposite i am horrible at
characters and it is the hardest part
for me and i think for a lot of the
people
um in the infinite journeys challenge
who who participated i think we all we
all really struggle with the character
side of things um
it's very it's
very difficult there's a lot to deal
with um
[Music]
a whole lot of just technical
maneuvering in order to get something
that looks good and then you have to
animate it man like is this
yeah this is yeah it's hand animated
wow and i mean i kind of i i didn't even
really plan it this way but ended up
being relatively easy in terms of
character animation goes just because
the way the pedals work is like i just
rotated the pedals and i'm like ah his
legs are animated already it's sweet
so that's uh
right
um yes yeah so yes his feet are
literally just tied to the pedals and i
had to like rotate the pedals to kind of
like mimic his feets movement so it's
like pedal directed yeah um but yeah it
ends up like looking fine i thought i
had to do a lot more shifting with the
legs to like get it being really
realistic and to be honest i probably do
if i want to be thorough but like just
having the whole pedal system rotating
it's like eh it works looks good
so you created this in blender is that
correct
yep
heck yeah man heck yeah when did you
first open blender when when were you
like huh
i think blender could be uh pretty
pretty fun let's try this out when was
that for you
uh it was whenever blender 2.8 came out
they had a huge update where they kind
of redid their ui and stuff um i was
like two years ago maybe i don't know
time is hard to keep track of nowadays
but
something like that two two years-ish
and and was that
the first time you got into 3d it was
two years ago
i've been uh i graduated from a vfx
school in 2012 so i've been doing like
10 years or so of
vfx and i was a maya user for a really
long time
yeah that's like the industry standard
right is maya
yeah but uh like maya for me and maybe
it's just because i learned like i was
like just kind of not the best artist
for a while using bias like i didn't
learn a lot of like there's some stuff
that i just avoided and for so long maya
was like a confusing program for me
and then i came into blender with like
so much more 3d knowledge to where i
could just learn the things that i
needed to know really quickly and
blender itself was set up to be
relatively easy to use in my experience
so it was like really easy to just
develop a workflow for blender and i
just kind of naturally transitioned to
it
i think they both have their strengths
for sure and
i still model in maya just because i
have so much muscle memory with modeling
like i can't model anything in blender
it takes too long
yeah modeling is
i i have trouble myself
um in in cinema
i feel like i'm just
crawling on the floor scrounging my way
through and like just barely passing you
know and it's a frustrating feeling
because
it sucks to be feel like you're you're
chained to a wall and you're like trying
to like you're trying to move forward
but like you're just ah you know you
can't um it's one of those things it
just takes like hours of just pure work
like it's like almost like an instrument
you just need the muscle memory to like
every till that you want you want to be
able to access it right away as soon as
you think of it
and like i have that with maya i don't
have that with blender and i don't want
to develop that with plunder so i just
model in maya and then bring it into
blender now
that's great that's very that's very
smart man it's like you do
and i think that's a good takeaway for
people um in the chat is like
you know it's
you don't have to just use one program
um
you use what works for you and
for some people that's to model in
another program bring it into another
program
um
and whatever whatever like your workflow
is so
speaking of workflow
um
can you can you show me or or break down
or talk about
your process with this what's the first
thing you do when you're like okay
there's a 3d challenge
what what's next
uh i like i spend like
like four or five days i would say just
on the idea itself and like making sure
like my brain likes it enough to like
like i know i'm spending this a month on
this thing
and if i'm not like wholeheartedly into
it i'm just gonna like get tired by a
week and a half and then like slowly
crawl towards some kind of result so
yeah i definitely take time just like
letting things simmer not even working
not even necessarily like concepting
just like
what's an idea and then sleep on it and
like do i still like it no okay next one
or are you just sitting there like this
just like
just like
thinking hard or are you writing typing
like what do you do
um
i'll do honestly i will just like think
about it and just like i mean i'll
definitely like yeah just sit there on
the couch and like stare towards the
wall like yeah yeah maybe
um i mean it's not even that far from
the truth like i'll just think about it
um like while i'm like
absorbing other media watching tv or
whatever and or just whatever pops into
my head when i learn about the prompt
yeah um and then just like
i mean i can think for a night about an
idea and like whether or not i can put
that into motion and then just like i'll
definitely thinking about it over the
course of the day like how i would go
about each step and just like think
about if it works if i still like it
um yeah so yeah basically it's just like
an idea formation
process but
i think what you said uh a couple
minutes ago is really important
you wanted to pick an idea that you
could live with for a month not just a
week um
and
because if you get tired of it
like you said you're just gonna hate the
process and
you may not even finish the art and if
you do it's going to be
you know potentially uninspired
and just yeah
whatever because i think it's it's
important to think beyond the contest
too like this is a piece that's going to
be on your portfolio and it's like
i don't know you want to represent you
in some way and just like
not just get it done for the contest so
it's like yeah it's a month long and
there's a deadline related to the
contest but you want to make sure you
can
finish the piece and by the end it's not
like well it's just gotta fit these
guidelines and
like i don't know
to me it's like i use the contest as a
framework for creating a portfolio piece
it's kind of like my mental way of
framing it i guess that kind of helps me
organize things
yeah
yeah yeah that's
that makes sense to me that definitely
makes sense
um
sorry y'all i'm doing two things at once
here let me get this back up and go
um so how long does it take to concept
this and then what do you do from there
um so once i like liked the idea
man we just watched tyler's concepts
so maybe mine will be refreshing uh
uh change of pace and let us know if you
want to if you want us to share let's
let's switch over and share your screen
yeah
all right hopefully my
beautiful concept is on screen
yeah yeah thank you soto it's looking
good
sweet yeah we got you
all right yeah so i mean i i definitely
do not fancy myself a 2d artist but
like i mean
you actually talked about this in
talking with tyler like your concepts
are just like to get the idea on paper
and
like that's it and then you can kind of
fill in the blanks like
so i just had like my ideas i had like
this kid that i knew i wanted to be like
i wanted to be kid's imagination that
was kind of the idea that i ended up
landing on that i liked and i could
stick with yeah
um
and then i knew i wanted that like
scrolling background thing as part of
his little invention and you could see i
have like the bike pedal system already
kind of like that was the main idea is
that this kid had built this bike pedal
thing
controlling the scrolling background
and then i thought maybe had like a
teddy bear or whatever like it was very
calvin and hobbes inspired yeah it's
like a mixture like my two main things i
kept thinking about are calvin and
hobbes and then uh up carl fredrickson
as a kid yeah like the like spirit of
adventure whole vibe yeah so
um yeah from there
like i just trying to try to channel
that energy and then just jot the idea
down because i do think concepting is no
matter how bad you are at concepting or
think you are bad at it like
it's so important to just have like a
solid like this is the idea it doesn't
matter if it looks good it's just like
it's a thing that you can like remind
yourself later if you get a little bit
lost like this is the important stuff
okay y'all you heard it that's two for
two now all right concepting just do a
sketch it doesn't have to look good but
it guides your direction
through the end of the project um
i started doing that a little too late i
think i started doing that maybe like
four
parallel dimensions the first three 3d
challenge that was the first time i ever
concepted anything before i created and
it
dude it made the biggest difference it
was insane so it's good to know that
like i'm kind of on track
and and like even if it's not concept i
mean i definitely recommend it but if
you don't have a concept you should at
least have like a huge like
mood board or reference board just like
stuff that inspires your idea or is
really close to your idea that you found
from other media um like all that stuff
helps just like ground like it's again
like just from to help from getting lost
during the process absolutely absolutely
um okay so you put this together just in
what uh photoshop i assume yeah yeah
just to yeah quick thing in photoshop
and then yeah i just like literally
wrote down things that were like i
considered staples of the idea
like the boys gonna be nerdy i don't
know if that even came across but
clearly
and then i wanted to have a really cool
teddy bear and the fact that the teddy
bear was cool was important to me and
that he would definitely have
sunglasses on and then the pedal driven
system
and then like that's all it is i don't
even have the background in because i
knew what it was going to be like i knew
it was going to be the scrolling thing
so i don't need to draw that because i
know what it's going to be so
like from there i i definitely just
wanted to jump right into production
once like my idea was down
okay okay so i i love the fact that
you're like the dude is nerdy
and and you said you don't know what
that is and like i really just i really
was like thinking about it you know
and yeah
i think it's that i think it's the
skinny neck i think it's the toothpick
now
for me personally i don't know but maybe
chicken legs too who knows but yeah i
didn't make those connections but maybe
that was like a subconscious like what
is what is nerdy how do i even cause
like if he had no if if it was just head
to tr like to like the what are the what
are these muscles the like wwe muscles
i don't even know
oh like some trips if it was yeah yeah
if he was just like a turtleman like
it'd be it'd be a different vibe for
sure
oh yeah it would
okay so you got all right jokes aside
you got um your sketch where you go from
here
um then i just honestly start jumping in
like because at this point it's like i
know there's so many things i have to
get done it's like i know
i guess the best like so there's so many
assets that need to be made
and there's some that i'm not sure about
and there's some that absolutely have to
be made so i know i need a kid like this
this character model's got to get done
so i just immediately started modeling
the character and again like i said like
character art is my jam so
that's the first thing i was drawn to
anyway i knew i was gonna make this
character
so it's like this thing's gotta get done
yeah a bunch of other stuff has to get
done so i but i just knew this one had
to get done so i started with the
character
um
i have a little uh
thing anyway
this is your final scene we're looking
at basically right oh yeah this is my
final blender scene yeah
um
yeah so i modeled them in zbrush
and um
let's see i have like the actual
little breakdown video i think this is
it
yeah
there's modeling in zbrush
sweet
um and as you can see
the face turned out all right but it
goes through some really rough uh
iterations
so if that's encouraging to people who
are like oh man
experienced character artists are so
good it's like you still go through the
the growing pains of figuring out how a
face is supposed to look and also like i
don't um
i didn't ever work in like the pixar
style which is part of why i wanted to
do
this kind of thing like my last
character was like this
creepy witch gal uh
the gersetti contest
okay so this is a new style for you as
well
yeah wow dude
what the heck
that's insane dude that's crazy i'll
show i'll briefly show my other this is
what i just finished this project wow
that's nice it's like totally i was like
i need to not do creepy stuff for a bit
that's like some elden ring level that's
amazing
dark souls is definitely inspiration but
yeah i wanted to get away from that so i
wanted to do pixar style i hadn't done i
did cartoony stuff and i was like kind
of learning 3d but none of it looked
good so i really wanted to get like
close this time and like try to really
nail it
as best as i could with my abilities so
yeah
i wasn't too worried about environment
stuff like the workflow i feel like for
that is more or less the same as like
photo real stuff like pixar environments
are honestly basically photo real
environments yeah the characters are so
stylized yeah
so i love that character was was the one
i wanted to really get right so how did
you do the clothes and everything
that's all sculpted
um i didn't worry about colossums i did
like some blend shape stuff for the
wrinkles like as he turns but that's
honestly unnecessary like it's all
sculpted
i made him like lanky enough and his his
clothes are like tight fitting enough to
where i didn't have to worry about
simulations
being weird looking
like if they just follow his arms it
doesn't really draw attention that
they're not simulated so that was kind
of intentional okay all right so you
just said screw it for the simulations
and you just made it part of his
movement i think that's very smart um
that's using your time very wisely
yeah that was totally what it was as a
time constraint thing even for the back
this thing well especially i would say
for the
the screen
i did not do simulations at all for this
it is entirely like blend shape driven
so that i can control like when the uh
wrinkles happen and when they
um
like when they trigger how strong the
wrinkles are going to be when it pulls
on like i can i have control over all
that whereas with like simulation i
don't know if the simulation is going to
work out properly like
how do i get like
when it works i have to cache it and
then i can't touch it and like i didn't
want to have to fuss with all that i
wanted to make sure everything got done
on time is basically the main thing
okay so let me ask this you basically
um
so you had two options you could
simulate the background we're talking
about the specifically the background
now you could simulate that background
and bake it in but then it's like kind
of finicky and it may not work if you
change the vibe on the foreground
character and his speed and everything
and you have to resume it and it'll
probably take a little bit too much time
in the end
so you chose to essentially just do it
um
what's what's the best like terminology
for this like
it wasn't a simulation so it was a
blanket um i guess it's you could call
it blend shape uh based i guess
what is a blend shape
explain what a blend shape is uh so
blend shape is like you have a mesh and
on its own it looks a certain way
however you've modeled it how you made
it so in this case like
i'm turning off all the blend shapes
here this is the blanket
it's literally a flat plane with
there's like a blender lets you randomly
select faces and i just deleted random
faces oh okay cool and then so i have
like ways of
you can you can create a blend shape and
maya in my other called blend shapes in
blender they're actually called shape
keys they're commonly known as blend
shapes but anyway um
so i
created a blend shape and
um you can sculpt on it you can whatever
you want to do to the mesh after that
point
um you can create a version of the mesh
that is basically you're telling
vertices that you modified
that that they look this way now and you
can
you can flip between like your original
version and then the blend shape active
okay like a pretty terrible way to
explain it but yeah okay so it's
basically your key framing
like on and off and everything in
between essentially on a slider of like
in this case
the like cloth deformations
right exactly
and and you can use this for like facial
rigging is pretty common like a
character's face you'll do blend shape
for uh like a smile expression so you
can turn a smile on and off by going
from zero to one yeah um but in this
case i just made like layers and layers
of blanket wrinkles like some of them
are just like isolated to one area some
of them are like wrinkles over the
entire thing
and then i just like linked these to
like a noise modifier so that they would
just turn on and off randomly or in some
cases i would uh hand trigger them if it
was like important how they worked
okay so that's another like for flapping
it's like to get like a flapping kind of
a look
with the noise yeah yeah like the bottom
one was and then this one this one is
the blend shape that i use to
control like drag when you see uh the
hyper speed going when he goes into
hyper speed mode you can see the blanket
kind of drags a bit
like just just doing something simple
like this
will create that effect
and then because all this eventually is
like wrapped around the uh
there's a curve in here that guides the
whole thing so it's like all bound to
this curve modifier so all that's
happening while it's spinning around
the curve
so it's like it's
it's it's pretty quick to make once
you're familiar with blend shapes like
it's just sculpting in these wrinkles
and then once you have that you have
like complete control of how it's gonna
wrinkle when it's going to wrinkle which
is like just a relief because you don't
have to worry about your simulations
working properly not to mention like
simulating itself takes forever
it's one of the things i'm not an expert
on at all which is probably another part
of why i didn't use it
so i like that with my guns and what i
know i like that yeah it's very nice and
very simple and well well and uh it was
easily controlled so
yeah and that was the thing like i
definitely considered this project or
this challenge like a project management
challenge like tyler was talking so much
about how it was like the workflow was
important getting everything like like
you wanted to make sure he had
everything on track and that was me too
i'm like there's so much to do when you
have a character a foreground and a
background and like you can literally do
like anything
there's
like
i mean that's part of the idea or why i
had this like scrolling background thing
is it was relatively simple to i mean i
wanted to make sure it looked good but
it was not an exhausting background to
make and i could focus on the foreground
elements that i really wanted to make
look right i mean i knew just making the
assets was going to take forever too so
i wanted to make sure i could get this
thing done
so
so talking about making the assets uh
how did you create this cardboard
look with the marker did you actually
like
there's no way you actually like
use the sharpie you're just in photoshop
with like a
with a certain brush that looks like
that right
yeah it's substance painting and yeah
it's just like a black brush it's like
50 opacity so it has like some it looks
like it's
like you know bleeding a bit
and yeah
uh the cardboard was like i had kind of
a workflow for making that because i
wanted to make sure it actually had like
the corrugation on the inside
um
but i was yeah substance painter i had
the uv cardboard and i literally just
drew on it like a kid
that sounds like the best dude like this
takes me back to the the cardboard
warfare days where i was literally
drawing on cardboard um
sharpieing out like a
you know like an airplane cockpit kind
of a thing
um
cardboard is the greatest material
i mean man there's so many things as a
kid like this whole project brought me
back to like
when it was the only material available
to make any kind of craft for me
like
making like robot
costumes and stuff that was good times
yeah and this this totally captures that
um dude like your details with like the
recycle sign and
and like the umbrella thing and
i'm so paranoid about like making
everything from scratch so i probably
could have just grabbed a recycle sign
from online but i like went into
photoshop and like
vector curved out a
vector jeez dude okay man that's
that's definitely one of those moments
where i'm like why am i why am i doing
this but i did it whatever
um is there any like last little pieces
you want to touch on that you think are
good takeaways for the audience before
we hop into q a
[Music]
i um know i guess like
this is kind of something that is
i always think good advice for every bit
of art is like always
zoom out and look at the big picture i
mean i translate this most to sculpting
and it's probably one of the lessons
that i always have to teach myself
whenever i'm sculpting something
is like if something isn't looking the
way you want it to it's usually like
it's usually not the thing that you're
doing at that moment it's like i'm
sculpting wrinkles on a character and
i'm like oh this character's not looking
how i want it's usually because like the
skull shape is wrong or something like
more major is wrong
so my general advice is always like
think about the big picture of something
and then work
work more towards the smaller details
and you can apply it to like project
management too
it's like that's why i like concepting
and stuff is so important because it
focuses on the big picture and like you
can take track of the important things
and get those right and then work on the
small details that honestly don't matter
very much later
yeah that's my advice i guess that's
some solid advice i remember when people
came in uh when i was at corridor and we
did a render challenge together i think
we had two hours yeah we had two hours
to create something
and
you know i think he's mentioned this
uh
a few times
but he talks about the idea of getting
to a version
that you could post
like just get quick as quickly as you
can
get to something that is fine that's
just
doable it's not inspired it's not
uh
it's not amazing it's not detailed but
if it came down to it and you had to
post it you could post it
um yeah versus like
going super detailed on some like head
or something and it's like this is what
is this is nothing um yep so once you
have the the you know i call it like the
big the big brush strokes um or or even
like
even a sketch you know like your concept
basically you have
kind of the whole vibe there
then you can start going in for details
and i
get
i get real
obsessed with the details and
i have so easy to do
yeah yeah actually it's usually the fun
stuff to do so you want to get to it and
like convince yourself that you're in
the right spot to start doing details
when
in reality in reality a lot of the time
you're not
it's like that's always something that i
have to like check in with myself
because i think
like everybody has a habit i think it's
like so common you want to get to like
that good stuff you want to make the
wood details but it's like your thing
already doesn't look like wood why are
you putting wood details on it
yeah
no matter how experienced you are i feel
like you run into that it's like a thing
you have to learn to watch out for
absolutely absolutely um y'all get it
get your q a questions in here
uh for alex
uh we have a we have a handful of
minutes here so i wanna i wanna get your
guys questions in before
uh alex leaves us um
yeah i
i i struggle with just wanting to focus
on the details
and i think i waste a lot of time
on the details um that's one of my
takeaways from from my infinite journeys
submission i'm putting out i'm currently
writing a breakdown on it right now
that'll come out in two weeks from now
and it's interesting because the video
is turning into like
here's how i failed and like how i'm
going to prevent that in the future
um that's important that's i mean
arguably more important than a video of
like here's how everything got done
perfectly
[Laughter]
yeah there's a there's a lot of those on
youtube for sure um but i think as long
as you're just being honest and if i'm
being honest with myself like i didn't
think mine turned out too great and i
wasn't too happy with it so
um i wanna i wanna get into that and i
wanna talk about that so i think that'll
be cool that's two weeks from now but
anyway this is about you let's see what
kind of uh let's see what questions we
got uh neko asks how did you do the hair
um
uh
this person they say they're not good
with simulations yeah how did you do the
hair
uh the hair is blender's hair system
which it uses like a particle system you
can kind of uh paint on like sections
where it it makes little guide particles
um
well anyway there's there's guidelines
or there's uh tutorials for that but
sure the main like theory
with hair that is kind of common with a
lot of ways to do it is
i started like
um let's see are we in the hair section
like i start with the lower hairs that
are like really fine and small just like
at the base and then i do the hairs on
top last and i always felt like that's
a way to not get exhausted like do them
in little chunks instead of making like
a whole like head of hair and then
trying to like style it and cut it
like make make one chunk at a time get
one chunk looking good
and then move on to the next chunk
um that's my like that's my like theory
towards hair making
like the technical stuff
that's terrifying oh my god jeez dude
said that as your profile picture
goodness
oh yeah there's a lot of
fun i could have with this
his he can make some really goofy facial
expressions because i i could not rig
him properly i had to like i'd like cluj
together some like blend shapes like oh
i hope the smile looks good
like
uh it's it's just too much
that's amazing um
uh we're getting through these q and a's
here what's uh
can you touch on the pedal rig briefly
oh yeah um
because the pedal ring it like controls
it goes down like it's it's pretty
complicated it's really cool you set
that up uh yeah let's see so it's all
it's driven a lot by what are called
drivers in blender and set driven keys
in maya where you just have one
like for instance rotational value
controls a bunch of rotational values
okay um
which yeah they're called drivers and
like for this rig
i just have
whenever this rotates like this whole
pedal system here
why am i still in the
renderer it'll be much faster if i do
this this controls like all this other
stuff and it's literally just like i
know this thing
uh rotates
and then i can make this bike chain move
by like i forgot even how i got that to
work but you can use drivers to link
those two things okay so whenever this
rotates the bike chain thing rotates and
then i do the same thing with this this
uh
gear thing whenever
the bike pedal rotates this gear rotates
um but basically just you you could use
drivers to get that effect it's like a
series of drivers it's way easier than
it seems honestly and that's what that's
what you would just
you know look up on youtube and find the
tutorials for drivers essentially in
blender yeah yeah i don't want to like
here's how you click this button yeah
but yeah if you look up drivers you'll
find the the methods to create that it's
like this is a pretty simple uh usage of
gyrus i would say
that's awesome
really
it's very effective and very simple it
seems like i just have to hand animate
like the like the bite chain moving i've
got like these these things that like
control the up and down of the bike
chain same with like in the hyper speed
moves i have these controllers for that
but like the the full
the big pieces moving is uh
it's uh mostly driven by drivers
sweet okay
that works that way too
uh final question here
uh do you have any tips and tools for uh
oh tips or tools i like tools okay
that's cool for time management
and project planning
um
i can't say i have any tools for that
um
i would like that's really back where
concepting comes in and like
i've been doing 3d for like 10 years so
i know roughly like how long a model is
probably gonna take how many assets i'm
gonna be making in a scene so maybe i
could just say like keep track of how
many assets you're gonna probably want
in your scene like if you're gonna want
a busy scene you're probably gonna have
a bunch of little doodads like kind of
keep a mental track of how many
those are gonna be and like account like
yeah maybe it might be as simple as a
pencil but if you have a thousand
thousand pencils in your scene it's
probably gonna take a while so like keep
track of your assets what you're gonna
need to make for the scene
roughly keep track of how long that
might take you
like to whatever your modeling ability
is
and then you can get a rough idea of how
long it's gonna take but it is really
like coming down to like
knowing as much as you can as early as
you can what you're gonna need for your
scene
and how long it's probably gonna take
you and just ask yourself like is this
even possible
okay yeah i ne i need to take that
advice desperately need to take that
advice because i bite off more than i
can chew
and it screws me uh it has screwed me
time and time again
um so i think what i'm what i'm gonna
try and do and i talk about this in in
um
in my breakdown that's coming out soon
here but basically
i
i overestimated the amount of days i
actually had
and
um
underestimated the amount of work that
was needed to be done and i need to do
the opposite i essentially need to like
be realistic with the amount of days i
actually have to work um one month is
not 30 days for me it's 20
[Music]
because you know i like to have a
weekend
um
and then but those days are also not
full days they're half days because i
have you know i'm running youtube
channel doing the discord doing weekly
challenges and stuff it's not just art
every day
so it's like okay that's really like 10
days
and then
i'll
knowing that i have 10 days
let me see if i can create something in
five days
let me let me aim for a five day idea
and then yep i can take those five those
extra five days
if it really turns into a five-day idea
and i complete it in five days take
those extra five days to like max out
and and add the spice and i think i'm
gonna try that on the next the next
challenge and even future projects
so i'm i'm experimenting with that and i
really do need
the time management and advice so i
appreciate i appreciate your take on
that
and it's also like
uh modeling like plan your tasks towards
your camera too it's important to come
back to where your camera is and like is
the stuff i'm working on even gonna be
seen and to what extent you can use it
as a guide to like what's the most
important thing
yep you are you're speaking
the glorious ones my cardboard stuff has
like stuff written down here and i was
like oh that looks cool it says like
first mate's chair for the like bears
seat
you can't even see it in the camera and
i'm like all right thankfully it didn't
take long but it's like you don't have
to do that stuff if you're not going to
see it so
yeah it's important to always look back
to your camera and be like what actually
matters
yeah yeah that's another one that i
learned this time around too
everyone has to learn that stuff and you
always learn it best through making the
mistake
yeah no one can tell you to do that
stuff and like oh okay now i'm never
gonna make that mistake no
you're always gonna like i get i made
that mistake this project and i knew
that that happens so it's just gonna
happen absolutely um alex i really
appreciate your time man thank you so
much for for doing this congratulations
again on third place and uh
where can people find you
before you leave um
i'm also not very so uh active on social
media i have a instagram
at borbor
uh b-o-r-r-b-o-r-r-e
all right and then i'm on art station
just under my name uh but i'm not super
active on i mean i try to post whenever
i make something cool on our instagram
and art station that's about it
pretty simple but thank you for having
me
thank you for uh for uh choosing me i'm
honored
and i'm happy to be here and discuss my
workflow it's been great yeah man keep
it up i can't wait to see more from you
um and we'll be in touch man we'll talk
soon yeah
sweet sounds good all right peace out
alex
peace out
what
who
who's they
who's this
it's ewing
what's up you and how you doing man
thanks man i can't believe i'm here this
is like imposter syndrome
[Laughter]
dude your art is so nice man i love
everything about the color
the characters
dude you crushed it congrats on second
place man thanks man thanks how are you
doing today what's going on
it's the evening here in scotland so uh
just chilling uh just watching your
stream so far it's been good
sweet learning a lot about 3d yeah
hopefully hopefully um that's a good
thing yeah that's a good thing
um so you're in scotland what time is it
right now in scotland
it's uh it's way past eight so early
evening oh that's not bad at all yeah i
was i was afraid this stream would be
like at four in the morning
just be completely dead dude that
happened with will with william foshea
like we got started at like
midnight his time and then it was a five
hour stream and like oh no yeah that
dude fake energy for it yeah that dude's
a champ for sure um
but uh
yeah this is this is about you man i i
really
really uh appreciate you taking the time
to be on here and i think your work is
incredibly excited to dig into it
um
but first
just a little bit back a little bit of
background about yourself like what
was this how long have you been working
in 3d we'll start there
well i started at university uh robert
gardens uh i did computing for graphics
and animation i did a whole two modules
on 3d
where we did a crash course on
architectural modeling and then a quick
course on character stuff but i actually
really learned everything uh working at
my company they took me on in a
placement
this was about 2014 and the placement
was for uh cervitec viscom it's a health
and safety company okay and i did a
mixture of filming with them
and doing the 3d for the filming they
just chucked me into a helicopter and
put a camera on my face
and start and told me just to reenact
various scenes of peeing on a seat belt
bracing for a crash
so you're an actor then for this health
company oh i'm not an accident
what was so weird about it was
i've probably been in every single like
helicopter in the uk i've never been in
the air it was all movie magic we uh oh
we whited out the windows
and just pretended and then cut to
studio of me inflating a life jacket
uh and then they had some other guy who
actually was trained for uh the water
stuff going under and how to use the
life jacket and the rebreather stuff
okay okay uh so while i wasn't doing
that i was doing a crash course
literally on greyskill gorilla trying to
cram in as much as possible about 3d and
they just basically got me to where i am
yeah no same same all right so yeah you
created this in cinema 4d
uh grayscale gorilla is how i learned
c4d
um
and they they're just they're the best
man they they have it all and their
tutorials are just super so good dude
man they're and they're nice guys too
that's the best thing
all our stuff was a physical base for
renderer and
we've been i've been doing that since
2014.
and
say that one more time
physical based render cpu based render
the slowest renderer known to man yes
okay so that's what you've been working
on like that's
that's what i've been working on until
january where we got a bunch of new
machines with uh 39 days and there was
no point having these machines without
being able to actually use them so we
got redshift so i've been crash course
in redshift this year basically
and your your uh competition is like bam
this is perfect i can learn how to
texture with it i can learn how to light
and while i'm doing this it will improve
my uh work at work so that's basically
that the reason why i entered this
competition was to learn
that's a win-win for sure it really i
did not expect to be here
it's a win-win win that's a three for a
win-win win yeah that's crazy okay all
right so you were using physical by the
way physical render is like
physical render is rough guys i don't
know it's like the slow is cpu based
it's extremely slow it doesn't even look
that good
um i mean i guess it looks fine well you
can get it there yeah it's basically
it's hours if it's a manual there for a
singular frame yeah is it just it's yeah
and
i basically majority of my scenes at
work we just couldn't use
global illumination half the time if
we're we're trying to get tons and tons
of scenes like for an oil rig induction
it's hundreds of scenes so you can't be
spending an hour per frame you're trying
to keep it down to five to three minutes
per frame
so
things are changing
that's good man that's good that's good
i'm glad that you're on arnold um
or it's a redshift actually sorry i'm
glad you're on redshift um
i
ren got me on to octane
i was on physical render for the longest
time i was dead set on learning physical
render because i'm like nope that's what
the program is you chose
yeah yeah it was dude it was dumb it was
dumb it was like i was like this is what
the program ships with i gotta learn the
base program first before i start adding
all these plugins like
i don't know like i'm not gonna know
what i know and don't know if i don't
know what the program ships with so and
he was like dude dude he was like
pulling his hair i was like what are you
doing i was like nope i got this and it
was the corridor video
it was the foam fortnite video
where that was like a massive stack of
foam noodles that i like dude my
computer was like
i could have cooked an egg on my
computer so hot and like
it was all physical render and it took i
think it was like it's like 30 minutes
per frame and it took like
four days
and
after that project ren just grabbed me
by the shoulders and he was like you are
learning octane and then he showed me
octane jesus
and i those were i just did those
tutorials and greyscale stuff um and
yeah that was the end of that
octane would have been a strong
contender for us but one of the main
reasons why we kept physical for so long
was we've got so many assets started
stuck on the physical render we're gonna
have to just update an entire fleet of
helicopters to be able to use it because
it's
redshift uses completely different
textures to uh the physical based
renderer and different
lighting different camera and basically
across the board you're gonna have to
change it and the texture system it's a
node based uh texture system for red
shift
so
in the physical render you just stack
all your textures on top of your model
and so you could just have your tons of
decals for your company logos on top you
can't do that anymore it's all got to be
kind of baked into the one node texture
in a material blender
yeah that's great i hate it
yeah yeah it seems octane too it's like
it's really hard to like
get logos or stickers or
anything in in a specific spot unless
it's like an outfit
yeah
but at the end of the day everything
else is so much better somewhere faster
and the fact you can see your lighting
in real time i'm preaching this to
people that all already know this but i
just love it yeah yeah okay so let's
let's
let's start focusing here on the art
itself um and we're gonna kind of go
through
very similar what we're doing with the
last artists so
um
the contest comes along you hear about
it
how do you come up with this idea what
is this
so it would have been about the 5th of
february i was in a car ride and i
actually saw this contest like okay
i'm going to do this and i was just it
was about a six-hour car journey there
and back to edinburgh so we just i
started brainstorming ideas
and a lot of it was i was thinking about
video games i liked and what could what
i could do really good in the cinema 4d
so when i came back i created a bunch of
mood boards
let's get some up here
and the first thing that i thought up
was monkey islands
one of my favorite um
monkey island adventure games yeah it's
an ancient point adventure game okay
um this is uh art from like the special
edition
and like a concept art and i was
thinking i saw this picture
and it brought me back to playing it and
i just loved the creepy voodoo vibe of
it all fixed fog atmosphere in the
jungle and i knew like that's what i
want for my my background kind of like
creepy sinister
but then go the complete opposite
direction for the uh interior i love
these the style of these uh these ships
that have just kind of been like bashed
together barely hell just teetering on
the edge
and
so i i just ran with this idea and just
jumped straight into cinema i i just
rolled with it and
i completely started with something that
doesn't look a thing like
what i ended up with
it was um the basic idea was i would
just have this guy sleeping on a boat to
summon the best best sleep of his life
he was just going down a stream in this
creepy jungle skulls and voodoo and
everything going on behind cool i
quickly came into the problem that wait
this
this is a really fast camera
like i can't fit a lot into this
background because as before the stuff i
had on my scene it just flew by already
yeah so i was thinking okay i need to
bring this way up into the sky so i
flipped it from being a boat to an
airship entrepreneurship i i feel like
you can't really just have a guy
fast asleep at the wheel i i'm providing
a poor message really here
so i thought let's have some form of
cruise control and i was thinking you
know i could have like an elaborate
pulley system and my mind was racing and
i was like you know what
what the route i'm going down right now
i'm never finishing this project if i go
down this route let's keep it as simple
as possible we'll have someone else
drive the boat here's
you guys to notice my thing because
you're going to be seeing hundreds like
thousands of entries so i needed
something a little zany stuff up we'll
do a frog
so i love it kind of spawned the next
idea which was inspired by majora's mask
heck yeah this is kind of back story
that i kind of gave this whole scene
where
the frog was actually the man's best
friend
and they were artifacts indiana jones
style guys they're just traveling the
world looking for cool stuff yeah but
then one day he puts on this mask that
he finds and it turns him into a frog
so
now they're like well we need to find a
cure so they've been for years upon
years of searching the world trying to
find something to turn his best friend
back into human beings so i kind of gave
it like the uh happy mass salesman vibe
of just like covering the walls of as
many artifacts i could find
and like i just looked everywhere on the
net for anything that could be art
effect based and i found like a whole
library on uh sketchfab where it was um
yeah here it was a indiana university
library of 3d scans so i was just
finding a mixture of real world items
thrown in stuff like the majora's mask
and
weapons and just popping it on the wall
whoa okay so so
you're saying that
two things uh they're putting masks a
mask turned him into a frog and they're
trying to turn him back into a human by
like finding other artifacts in this
world right and i created i used that
and i tried to like make that my main
story throughout and i crammed lots of
little easter eggs into the scene which
i'll show later on of just uh like
stories books have got like their latest
find and what they're going for
and he's got scrolls of maps on on the
counter trying to find and it's just
like trying to heavily go into the story
aspect of this because i've been
watching a lot of um
adam savage's uh test the channel on
youtube
and i just love when he's whenever he's
doing a build he's always going on about
how he's weathering how he's trying to
tell a story of kit bashing and i try to
take that approach with this project and
just
really just tell a story with my art
that's so important and i think it shows
man it's like the story
is the secret sauce i think
you can have a technically proficient
scene even a scene that looks nice but
if there's no story then who cares
and just anything to just grab your
guy's attention because as i'm saying
like there's so many entries it could it
could be really technically sound but if
it's not got a good enough story it'll
just get buried so i just really wanted
to
emphasize that point
so
that was for the interior i got that all
down but i was rolling back to what i
said about the background uh now that i
was going for a more uh aerial view
i was thinking along the lines of um
xenoblades
i've never actually played it
but i i love the concept art it's it's a
big rpg where there's these massive uh
giants where all the people are actually
living on them and they're frozen in
time like mid conflict
and it's just they're so high in the sky
and there's just clouds everywhere and i
just love the idea of having these
massive objects at in the distance which
also just helped with the video because
the camera was moving so fast it needed
to be massive to be seen on screen the
entire time yes so i
i ran with that idea and mixed it in
with your classic
skull island from the likes of
king kong and pirates of the caribbean
and i really liked this concept out here
by j olivia and the piratey theme uh
with the light coming from the eyes yeah
so i wanted to combine this with the
oversized elements of uh xenoblades and
that's where like the arch uh coming
over this the top of the skull comes
from the trees all the going across the
top and then the light as you see here
coming from the skull and that once i
had all those four uh ideas kind of
brought together i was just at the races
so you didn't even you know this touched
a 3d program yet you're just guys
well that's the no no no i was i was in
the midst of this in the 3d like this
was me like coming up with ideas as i
was making it this is not normally how i
work
i was it was a kind of
kind of winging it but like trying to
come off ideas spawning off other ideas
like the majora's mask frog spawning uh
like the story behind it like why are
they here well they're looking for an
artifact okay so they're they're looking
at this massive skull in the distance
because this skull has the mask that
they're looking for that's so cool
dude i love that so much i love that
those themes uh i mean i'm such an
indiana jones
fan and like but turning indiana jones
into more of like that
like
dark i mean indiana jones is dark too
but like it's like indiana jones
with that
uh like pirate uh twist to it i love
that yeah i i just love
i love the pirate theme i ever remember
being a kid uh in disneyland the pirates
of the caribbean dude that's the best
ride yeah it's so cute well i liked it
before they changed it with uh captain
jack sparrow because it like focuses too
much on him where before it was just
lots of little stories yeah yeah but i
still love it this is so good so i just
really wanted to bring that into my uh
into my project
amazing okay so yeah where are you at at
this point what's what's next
so
i've got various uh
stages now of my scene when i was
building it up so when i first i've got
it here on uh cinema 4d when i first
started i basically just used a complete
blank plane in the background and just
put some random art that i kind of just
get the general color scheme that i
wanted and use that as a light
and then i lit kind of the the wind to
window areas and i just kip bashed the
entire um interior out
i looked around as many different types
of uh piratey ship assets as possible
just collected a huge uh library of it
and then this is the kind of going back
to the adam savage style just building
building it up try and create a story
why is this here does this does this
help push the story along
and yeah i did it all just without any
textures to begin with just to get the
idea see if the visual weight works yeah
it was around about when i was at this
stage my girlfriend walked in and she
was like
why is it facing left
oh no
so minus the the x value we're back on
track
wait so you're saying that
you're saying that the frog was on the
left and they were moving to the left
yeah they were
yeah so they were like moving backwards
uh i really hadn't been moving the
camera enough at that point oh so your
camera was still moving to the right
you're still moving to the right but
like
but the frog was looking out the back of
the bus essentially yeah i was so
focused on just building up the scene
without moving the camera that i
completely forgot the orientation
dude that's crazy that's why you need to
step away re-read the instructions
and don't get too laser-focused on what
you're doing because you can miss pretty
obvious things like that that's all
that's why it's always great to have
someone else have a look at stuff you're
doing good advice um very good advice
actually very like let's say that again
because i think that's really important
take time step away from what you're
doing
and
have someone else that you trust look at
it and just give you like they'll say
their their first couple thoughts and i
think those will be important
yeah
so
i then
started to uh add all the artifacts and
uh this was
the camera
scene fairly chokes
um
i added all these artifacts in from that
museum
site on sketchfab and like vibrate tags
onto them just so it kind of jiggles
along with the airship
um hey ewan can you do me a favor
yup if hopefully this won't break things
um can you share your screen on discord
with me so i can see
uh what you're looking at
oh right okay yeah um
okay there you go
yep
so
uh yeah all these artifacts out of the
vibrate tags kind of helpful for some
movement
and i started adding as much little
details as possible so
i started adding like books into the
foreground kind of showing there's the
general path of where they want to go
um i used various um
it was a mixture of just drawing on my
wacom tablet slash using uh just assets
i could find on shutterstock just for
like a waterfall scene
and then i just made up this banana mask
it's all nonsense but yeah it helps it
tells the story
so you drew these out yourself
yeah make sure then i drew this this uh
that was a shorter stock asset yeah i
was running at a time at that point
um
and then i was like i need to add lots
of just different scenes to like show
that these guys are partners
so
i took the frog
and uh decided
i gotta just have him jamming out
oh man dude that's just like the fact
that it's animated you didn't even it
was a snapshot in the final piece but
that's the beauty of maximo you can just
you can get any animation you need and
just throw it on and it just works
that's kind of the best thing ever dude
yeah
and uh where was the and then yeah i
just had the porch of the two this was
the older version of the frog the frog
itself um
gotta give credit where credit's due
we'll start with uh the main man the
man's called hopper and the frog is
called croaks
hopper uh i got his head from this guy
oh what's his name again um cg trader
makar militsky on cg trader
and then i took i took the head and i
attached it to an adobe fuse body adobe
fuse is no longer a thing anymore
and it shows because if you try to if
you still have it installed on your
machine and you try to launch it
it just doesn't launch you have to like
click the launch part and button about
30 times and then we'll open up about a
bajillion copies of it okay but when you
do get it working
it's uh it's kind of like a character
creator where you can uh choose from a
various uh series of presets so i got
these got them into a nice little
indiana jones style um costume and
colored it all to actually match what
was going for and for the frog um
he was
this mexican
poncho-esque frog from
sketch map is brilliant
a part of me wanted to keep the mexican
theme but i decided that i want to make
him a captain so i gave him a captain
head captain hands
which
it was a nice little sculpture sculpture
it is that fits better for sure
i ended up changing the texture you can
annoyingly you can't see it the in the
viewport here but you can see in the
final render where i kind of went for a
more neon neon green esque just to match
the color scheme and to keep it more
consistent because it was uh
multi-colored
um
so for the background
these are massive
these these look like they're massive
arches but it's actually they're just a
tiny little rock arch formation just a
3d scan
and
[Music]
yes it's just this tiny arch
and what i did was i selected various
vertices on the top
and i cloned a bajillion trees over the
top of it i just chopped the top off of
some palm trees
and just did a multi instance if i did
it as a standard object it would have
absolutely crashed the whole thing
yeah yeah what graphics card are you
using what is your what how much vram do
you have for your scene i've got a 38 so
it's uh 10 gigs i if i was using the
ones at work i would have been doing a
lot better but i had this is only
allowed to be done
that's great so 10 gigs is like
limitations yeah it is
it was more than enough yeah the fact i
got this all working in one scene as
well i didn't need to separate my scenes
which is in hindsight i really probably
should
you did it yeah you did it
it's great um for the clouds i use
volume uh vdbs
um so that's something the physical
renderer can never do and that again
like it's so simple you can get free
assets online for
for clouds and it's not just like a flat
plane this is a full 3d uh volumetric
cloud and i just pasted that a ton
across the scene and because it's just
rotating it around you can't tell it's
the same cloud over and over
that's for the skull uh
it is a ct scan of a gorilla
uh i took it and then yeah i went for
the whole absolute massive island aspect
of it made it huge scattered around
that's a hot 4d ocean
oh dude oh hot 4d what version of c40
are you in right now
so i'm in r285 um
january we got up today
yeah it was an absolute nightmare and we
had to get it on all the render clients
as well and this was more in my
co-worker he had to like code in uh
like a new api for each version of the
uh of the app to get it working what
okay some of the machines still don't
work because i think the last version i
was able to get hot4d by the way for the
people who don't know how 4d is like the
best ocean generator for cinema 4d but
it's old and it only works on like
like r22 and
and lower or something like that
but you're saying that you custom coded
it
with someone well it wasn't so much
custom coding it was just more a case of
updating it to use the latest version of
the cinema 4d api it's if you look on
the website where you can find hot4d
there's guys talking about tutorials and
how to do it
i
i went through it so many times and it
was so finicky but eventually got it
working the ocean actually we used
before uh hot 4d was infinite ocean and
it's really good it's like a nice pre
has tons of presets but it's physical
renderer only
so hot 4ds so far is my
top choice for redshift the best yeah
it's not that i have much experience
since january
from what you're saying as well yeah
yeah that's where to go yeah it's i saw
your tutorial with the car and the oil
rig in the background and that's where
we got the idea to use it dude it's the
best
it's so good um so really yeah
before you before you you go on we have
about 10 ish more minutes
um
if you want to
uh finish your uh your breakdown here
and then we can take it to q a if you
guys want to start asking questions
um start throwing them in at punisher me
in the chat and we'll see ya but yeah
please continue
so uh i'll jump into the animation
segment so
for animating it uh it was all hand
keyframed and uh oh the prize i got for
second phrase is the um the gloves extra
gloves yeah i wish i had them so much
for this project that's what's motivated
so much easier this was like the most
time-consuming aspect of the whole thing
was just animating this guy play the
banjo and i've got
no idea how to play the page
so i was just watching tons of clips on
youtube trying to replicate and i got
like a five second clip off of uh
pirates of the caribbean ride there's a
guy strumming away on a banjo
and i sped it up and i took it into
cinema 4d at the very beginning and i
just kind of used my ear and just try to
match each finger movement to cry
playing the banjo you referenced pirates
of the caribbean ride from disney yeah
yeah
story man
dude that's some deep
reference i did that for that then i
added this general sway to the guy just
so he wasn't so ultra rigid um so he was
just strumming away for the frog i got a
miximo uh
motion capture of him just driving uh
then i just uh cut off all the animation
there so he was in the right position
locked his hands to the steering wheel
but i i initially i wanted to have him
jumping all over the shop like hitting
levers and that but i quickly realized
yeah i'm running out of time here so
instead i just went full meta and just
had him like turn to the camera and
knowledge but that's funny enough so
let's go with that yeah
that worked out fine it's perfect
it's a chill scene you know it's it's
exactly i don't need to make it over the
top
and then the very i thought add a little
bit more flair add a bit more animation
have a flying turtle the background
because why not absolutely so i love
when i just had his arms up he just kind
of looks like he's like
that's a great dipstick
and that's just the pterodactyl model uh
mixed in with a 3d scan of a turtle
and then it was just a case of
uh adding layer upon layer in after
effects like when i go through this
you'll just think what is that done but
it just it all builds
uh together to just create the overall
scene i i did quite a few aov passes
that's so that's when you uh when you
render out your project you can
do
various passes to just highlight your
reflections your specular lights
and your shadows so i did a ton of those
and just slowly overlaid them onto my
model
or onto my render sorry and just slowly
build it up i
came into a weird glitch actually where
the guy's skin and the subsurface
scattering started glowing just briefly
at the very beginning so weird did a
nice little quick fix of that where i
just overlaid it again onto his face and
then just killed the red value
quick and dirty but did the job perfect
and i had a bunch of weird flickering
where i just re-rendered and um
overlaid down the top some dust layers
which you can get free off youtube and
just overlay it over the top
um
pipe smoke which is just you take a null
and cinema 4d
of the pipe smoke position take it into
after effects and then take some action
essentials and then there you go dude i
have always been
like trying to figure out how to get a
null from c4d into after effects it's
super simple
you just experience a project import it
kind of thing
yeah it's just when you save here it's
in the multi-pass image uh or sorry the
com that comes compositing project file
you just save it here and make sure
you've got a place to save it and then
just make sure you add all the data that
you need and yeah just put your null and
you're good to go dude this whole stream
is worth it just for that right there
and yeah it was just various various
layers uh various basically trying to
fix all the little problems in the scene
that were popping up for flickering
adding fake kind of volumetric light to
the frog coming through the window
because i felt it was a little dark up
in the corner cool and then yeah that's
like your before and and after uh
with with after effects just kind of
brighten everything up and just make
everything pop amazing dude it's it's
like
to me it's night and day um and there's
a lot of artists who had a really nice
final result but they just needed a
little bit of color correction and a
little bit of spice on it and
honestly just needed to be brightened up
and have a little bit more contrast and
i'm glad you did that
i did want to keep like the darker
colors but like a lot of times
especially when i was doing a lot of the
test renders before i was i figured oh
this looks great but i'm hiding so much
in my detail you need you can't be
afraid to show off what you've what
you've worked on because it's kind of
almost pointless
so just know just to know when to use
shadows in in certain places
and then from there yeah it was just a
bunch of sound effects but i won't play
that on the stream in case that messes
up with anything so if you guys have
questions for you and please um just at
punisher me here in the chat and
we're gonna ask some questions let me
scroll up and see if there's any blasted
no not yet get them in y'all get them in
and then we're gonna do uh we got one
one more artist left
to to interview um
but dude i i freaking love this color
scheme uh so so much
the green is like ah just so beautiful
and their
materials textures and the idea i think
it's absolutely wonderful and abs and
totally deserved dude second place
hundred percent like thank you so much
it's so difficult choosing the like
first second third fourth fifth because
they're all just so darn good
i was watching the top hundred live and
like i we i think you placed me like it
was like this was seven a odds uh when i
came up in the top hundred and i was
just like i'm never on this there's just
so many amazing
animations and i just was just so happy
to be on the top 100 itself let alone be
here on stream this is insane
thank you so much absolutely um i want
to note too that what visual
said
he said in the chat that that's the way
to do assets man you took the assets and
you use them and you hid them and you
use them in a in a custom unique way
that you can't tell their assets
yeah
that's the way to go
and the thing is
i kind of worked in the opposite level
to how alex did it where i've got like
all my engines and that and cogs down
here but they're all nonsense they're
not connected to anything it's just
there for visual flair there's a bit of
extra noise to add to help tell the
story
um but just a nice easy little addition
which can help
go a long way for your scenes just
loving stuff going with vibrate tags
just
going crazy in the background
like so
heck yeah that's awesome
um
color
uh color palette
the green what was that
uh based off of what what made you
choose that
i was going back to the uh monkey island
shot i was talking about the
voodoo-esque
voodoo lady in the jungle yeah i just
loved that kind of green vibe and just
the kind of creepiness i think in that
when i was doing my sound effects like
when it goes past the skull i've just
got this like
nordic choir going off just to kind of
make it a little unsettling as it
happens but then in the complete polar
opposite in the interior we just got our
man chilling with
captain frog taking him home
amazing
um let's see what else do we have here
uh how much per day did you work on the
project you just do like two hours a day
or was it kind of more broken up where
you just do huge chunks on the weekend
or what
well i work full time so it was a case
of just cramming uh the weekends when i
can and uh working evenings but the
majority of the work was done across two
weekends but like full-on days and then
trying to get here there in the weekend
but you gotta work gotta be careful not
to burn yourself out when you're doing
this stuff because if it's not fun then
why are you doing it this is you're
doing your entire day only doing 3d at
that stage so but i i just had a blast
in the doing this the whole way through
it's just so just super into the concept
and when you are it's no longer it
doesn't feel like a job it just feels
like fun
heck yeah man that's like there are
times when it does feel that way there
are times when it feels like a like a
dragon i think
cherishing the times where it is fun the
whole way through is like
you know it should it should it should
be cherished um exactly because it's a
hobby at the end of the day as well as
my job so
you should enjoy your hobbies
absolutely yeah absolutely and if you're
not you know like that can be scary it's
like i'm not enjoying my hobby what does
that mean well exactly yeah maybe go go
for a walk
take some time away take some time away
go outside yeah
i don't know it's a serious it's a
serious thing um
and i know it sounds like i'm joking but
honestly i i do think
a little break from
from your hobby if you're not having fun
doing your hobby you should take a break
from it for a while
um absolutely and really go outside go
for a walk um
go for a run that's actually how i got
majority of my ideas for this project
was just stepping away going outside
just having a think and away from a
screen and that's where i pretty much
came up with everything just not looking
at a screen yeah and it just helped a
ton
100 man well you and i really appreciate
you man thank you so much for coming and
doing this i can't wait to keep in touch
with you um and see what else you do uh
you're absolutely incredible
congratulations
thank you yeah brother all right have a
good one enjoy the rest of your evening
in scotland and uh i'll see you soon
so yup all right peace brother
chris
hey
dude what's up
not much how about you
getting through uh through the tail end
here of uh of an epic live stream man uh
thank you for your patience
yeah no problem been watching the stream
heck yeah dude heck yeah lots of good
stuff lots of good breakdowns
congratulations man
this first place right here
absolutely wonderful beautifully lit
beautifully rendered beautifully colored
beautifully designed beautifully
animated oh my god i can go on and on
and on
with this with this thing man um you
know before we hop into it because i
know we're going to get into the art
here give me a little bit of background
on yourself um
what what when was when was the first
time you opened a 3d program
ooh the first time i think would be with
cinema 4d
r14 i think and that was like in i think
2009 but like the the first time i
actually like really started to focus on
doing 3d um was pretty much like between
in like 2016 2017 um i started to
actually make uh some 3d art that i
would like consider to be um
good like i was proud of it pretty much
um
because before that it was it would
basically be like a few years
i go a few years between like trying to
do something in 3d but getting kind of
frustrated because uh they're definitely
like a learning curve with a lot of that
stuff
um but it was it was it was definitely
like the late 2016 that i started to
actually like uh focus on trying to do
like some kind of character or some kind
of environment
and then it just kind of went from there
okay so you started out and
kind of you would go
take breaks from 3d long long
breaks from 3d and
you would kind of come back to it and
because it is hard yeah it can be
discouraging right like trying to learn
a new language um
and
and not getting any sort of positive
feedback from the work you're putting
out when so how many years you said
between when you first started and work
that you started realizing was actually
pretty pretty nice
um yeah i guess it'd probably be like
around 20 10 to 20 16-ish so like six
years but um again there are long gaps
in between um then and there uh between
like me actually like working in cinema
4d on something yeah because the whole
time basically i was doing like
stop-motion animation before that
um as like my actual sort of job
and
as time went on i started to incorporate
like a little bit of like 3d stuff here
and there um yeah occasionally there'd
be like some some 3d like props things
like that um but is just easier to do in
3d um and they were like little baby
steps it kind of like led up to me
actually transitioning from doing stop
motion animation into doing 3d as like a
full-time career
okay so when you say baby steps you mean
like life milestones things that happen
like you got a job here et cetera et
cetera
or like you learn a specific
skill set yeah definitely learning a
specific skill set like with my entire
career um from even from after like 2016
2017 when i started doing things it was
still a bunch of baby steps working out
to basically where i am today um where i
do like one one sort of small project
after another and by like a small
project i mean like
um doing like these short like you know
10 second clips kind of like what i did
here um but on a smaller scale just to
learn like one aspect of doing things
like early on i did like
um i created like a or tried to create
like sort of a short film um that
focused on humanoid characters which is
something i never did before um
but i can't do fake i couldn't do faces
back then and i couldn't really do like
great human detailed modeling with like
fingers and like having like all sorts
of like um making the character look
more detailed um so for that character i
put like a mask on them um i made them
like wearing gloves all sorts of things
that like really tailored themselves
like what i was good at at that point
but still pushed me forward just like a
little bit um to make like a humanoid
character that i could actually like try
to make a story out of you know oh it's
very smart okay so you're taking on
you're taking on projects that push you
enough
uh
to to challenge you just enough so that
it's still looking good um but you're
also learning something while doing it
um and you're also doubling down on like
the things that you enjoy doing um and
the things that you do well so you're
playing your strengths but also
challenging yourself a little bit yeah
yeah cause if you like go back through
like if you look through like my entire
like instagram or something like that
what is it like with every like
uh my instagram is basically just my
name so it's uh chris theron um
t-h-e-o-r-i-n
okay if one of the mods wanted to put
that in the chat we can um we can pin it
up um so chris yeah i post there yeah i
post on my my youtube and my instagram
with all like the the sort of clips i do
um but yeah what's your youtube sorry
sorry sorry to catch you offline
uh yeah my youtube would be um chris et
um dash something's awry
um
yeah that's that's basically the best
way i can uh describe that but for sure
yeah we'll get all in the description um
as well yes once we go off but
okay yeah so yeah apologies continue
yeah no problem uh but yeah looking
through like my youtube and my instagram
um you can see like with every like
video i post like oh there's like a a
new technique he did there like oh he
added a did hair simulations on that one
and then the next one
um it's like oh he started like
experimenting with like adding like
little fibers to clothing things like
that um where every like little short
thing i do builds off of the previous
thing i just did
that makes a lot of sense um that was
actually something that corridor did
early on is and freddy as well when
freddie was doing freddie w
they would have
little vfx videos one to two minute
videos and they would just be testing
out an effect that they they know they
want to get better at or they they know
that they want to use later on for a
bigger idea
and each short film would be a way to
test out a new little technique um
and and and to learn so it's like a it's
a twofer you're putting out cool stuff
yeah exactly learning at the same time
um
okay so
let's focus on this art here
this is absolutely amazing to me the
thing that stands out is the lighting
it's so well lit
the animation too of course all the
detail you put into everything but
really it's it's the lighting and
i'll ask about you know
the beginning of the process
but i want you to touch on the lighting
first what are some things you're how
are you lighting the scene to have it
look so crispy and so punchy
oh yeah um
yeah so for lighting um that this was
like
like i'm all my things i'm just a fan of
doing like adding like a direct sunlight
into a room and just having come through
a window and look look at like the
global illumination sort of light
everything up i'm like a big fan of that
look so coming into this like i really
wanted to do something like that so
that's why we have
this sort of setup but
uh the main thing i learned like a few
years ago sort of trying to do this is
it's not just enough to set up like a
sunlight object and just shine it
through your window because even though
maybe your character's lit up uh you
very quickly realize that like
everything else it's like kind of there
like you can kind of see it but it
really has no definition so
when i actually go into my scene later
um you'll see there are so many
invisible lights
highlighting every corner of the scene
pretty much uh and i've turned them down
just enough so that they don't overpower
from like the center of the frame uh but
they're there so things like the bed in
the corner uh the tube in like the
bottom right corner uh and all like the
other shelves each of them has a
specific area like just like pointing at
it and very dimly lit because if i took
them all out uh it's pretty much
uh it's pretty much dark and sort of
kind of muddy in the corners and that
really doesn't let the colors and all
that stuff sort of shine do you i mean
you're welcome to pull up your scene now
we can hop into it
yeah sure
and then we'll go backwards then we'll
work backwards
yeah
um or rather we'll go back to the start
and then come forwards
um yeah okay so
was that a crash what was that
oh yeah
we'll come back to that one
um that's funny um
let's okay you gave us a little sampler
on the lights let's go to the beginning
we'll come back to the lights
um
how'd you start this thing the challenge
comes out
you get word of it and
what's the next thought in your
mind yeah so
uh yeah so coming up with the idea for
this um it was basically a collaboration
between me and my brother uh going back
and forth with uh what sort of idea we
wanted to do um originally we had the
idea of doing basically a murder mystery
on a train um where you basically um
where basically you see a dead a dead
body and like a detective and you have
like clues in like various corners um as
to like what sort of happened
um but that and but we couldn't really
figure out a way to make that sort of
feel unique in terms like its setting
um so that sort of that sort of
transitioned into
doing a cross between uh the turret
scene from star wars episode four where
they're like in the millennium falcon
with the turrets and they're swiveling
around shooting tie fighters yeah um and
then the
star creatures from super mario galaxy
where in that game you're able to
basically shoot a bunch of like gems
into their mouth until they basically
expand into an entire planet nice um and
the whole thing's just adorable so we
love doing that idea and that sort of
transitions into what we have now
amazing amazing so you guys collaborated
on like
the the ideation of like what
what would be like the final result and
you again once again use video games as
a reference i think that is a very
common thread
for
was it all of you guys at this point uh
myself included like games man it's such
a huge inspiration um that's that's cool
to hear so
going back to the beginning here how are
you starting a concept
uh you have your your overall idea but
how do you start finding out the
specifics and getting the different uh
references and whatnot
yeah so i mean here you can see my
pinterest sport i sort of set up for the
main character
since that really was the the focus of
the whole thing
um and i really like the idea of doing
sort of um this sort of mechanic
character who's just kind of like having
fun doing her job which apparently is
just feeding these like space nombler
looking aliens yeah um
yeah and so that and that basically
informed how i made the entire
environment where uh instead of like
your typical sort of sci-fi turret
spaceship set um it looks more kind of
like like a bedroom like a cozy um sort
of area we'd like to hang out and sort
of look down at the planets pretty much
um which is like the main reason you see
like there's a carpet on the floor you
got like a bed in the corner
and then just a bunch of posters and
coffee and all sorts of things that like
um you wouldn't really necessarily think
of when you like uh imagine a sci-fi
spaceship but that's really sort of the
idea that i love doing because not only
is it like super colorful to look at but
it just it doesn't feel so sort of like
as cold as you know a typical space
spaceship might be yeah it's
personalized to to her which is like it
feels very unique
yeah so for like these references like i
like the idea you can see they all sort
of or some of them have like the same
sort of like bright orange pants uh as a
focal point of the character's design
um and that transitioned into basically
the sketch that i had done
which is it's a pretty quick sketch um
really just for me but
um it gets down sort of the
i did to figure out sort of what
aspects i'm gonna pull from like these
pinterest boards like i'll take like the
pants from this thing uh the boots from
another thing and of course with like
any sci-fi thing you gotta have the
robot arm in there um it's basically
like a requirement so we had that as
well
um didn't bother with the face because i
i i'm not great at drawing faces um and
i knew once i started to sculpt the
actual thing it was gonna change anyways
so this was just to inform the clothing
themselves but um yeah once i did that
it basically transitioned into me doing
the actual zbrush sculpt uh which you
can see here so there are no eyebrows on
the character anymore so she looks a
little weird but you can see sort of
what the the final result ended up being
based on that that one sketch
that's beautiful how long did that take
uh this sculpt uh took about a full day
um
and that's using like a combination of
like elements that i sculpt from scratch
and then some uh other elements that are
like pre-made elements that i'll get and
i'll modify to sort of fit this
character um it's a great way to like
save on time without having to start
everything from scratch you know yeah
yeah
i need to learn zbrush goodness man
oh yeah zbrush it's a great program it
definitely has
um some
it definitely
is has a learning curve and can have a
few extra buttons that it actually needs
but
um it's a yeah it can be great for doing
very detailed sculpts
um but yeah going from that for the
character i just went right to
makesmode.com which is just a great way
to quickly rig your character and add
like a skeleton and just to see if like
everything's like sort of working right
um
because you can see like oh is this arm
too short is it too long are all the
proportions looking right
and it's just always it's always just
great to basically add a dancing
animation on any character you do just
to uh to see what that looks like so
you know
that's a great way to it's a great way
to get yourself started
um but i always i never use miximo as a
endpoint i'll always like download that
skeleton take it into cinema 4d and
basically let's clean up the all the
weights and all that make make sure it
sort of works as it should but here you
can see miximo really does do a great
job at getting you like most of the way
there without much work yeah so
[Music]
okay so you're starting with a character
um
just like alex both you guys started
with the characters the reason why you
started with the character
um well i guess it really is like i like
doing the things that sort of motivate
me to keep going pretty much yeah um and
i and personally i love doing like sort
of the character design and sort of i'm
getting all the shaders set up and
making sure this sort of informs the
overall style of the environment itself
yeah um
because my style is like a little bit
more cartoony a bit more stylized sort
of like the disney style um so it's
great for me to get the character all
set up put her in an environment and
then sculpt everything around that to
make sure it's basically all in the same
style um
because because i could just like take
like some um some real world looking
assets and just put it next to her but
if the proportions aren't like a little
cartoony
it's gonna feel a bit disconnected so um
i just wanted to start with that
character first and once i like get the
character done and see how it's looking
like that really motivates me to sort of
keep going and get like an environment
working around that character
man that's a good approach i did the
character dead last like
a day or two before i had to finish my
render
um
and it's really cool to see that your
character
informs the story
like that yep that makes so much sense i
i've always thought of that as you know
when i when i do short films or you know
i'm writing a movie right now
i'm starting with characters i figure
out the characters and then the
character and then the characters kind
of define where the story goes and i
never actually thought of that for 3d
before so that's really cool
yeah i mean really i mean you could do
it either you can certainly do it either
way but it really just comes down to
like what's the most important part of
your scene so yeah definitely for some
people it's like oh the environment is
definitely the more important part so we
got to start there but for me um i would
say i would say definitely yeah the
character
i wanted to really sort of make make
perfect with the amount of time i had
yeah it looks great okay so you have a
character what's next
yeah so next um once i get that miximo
rig all done um make it look good i
texture in substance painter uh render
in cinema 4d with redshift um and then
it's on to the facial rig um so i've
been doing this i've been making like
these characters for like my instagram
and my youtube for uh a few years now so
i've sort of created a workflow as to
what sort of uh blend shapes i'll need
for the facial rig um the like the
minimum amount of blend shapes i'll need
to create a expressive character that
can sort of achieve all the
um all the things i want to achieve so
yeah i even made this uh this creepy
looking uh blend shape chart basically
of all the things that i made for uh my
various characters
so you have things like you know a half
smile half frown
because these will both be like mirrored
on the left and right side pretty much
um various shrugs sneers
um and then sort of like eyebrows eye
eyelashes things like that that every
sort of uh emotion you might need to hit
and these are basically
i say they're bare minimum because you
can't put this character in like a pixar
film and have it sort of mesh with
everything else like like this character
can't speak at all there's not like the
blend shapes for it
but if she needs to smile or look sad or
look angry she can definitely achieve
that and so once i do all that which at
this point i've gotten it down to around
two and a half hours to create the
facial rig um just because i have this
whole like chart that i can follow point
to point um i end up with sort of this
test animation to just make sure i can
hit like all the basic emotions that i
might need to hit for the for the actual
short and even though you know in the
actual thing you can't really see her
face for most of it
i was really hoping to be able to see
her reflection in the glass itself
um
because what her emotion is while she's
actually shooting or feeding the uh the
space alien thing is also like super
important so even in compositing i took
like that reflection pass of the window
and made it like a lot brighter to to
actually see her face
um
yeah and so if we get back into cinema
4d after that that quick crash there
um
i can just
bring back uh bring back that model
and hey do you also mind sharing your
screen here on discord for me so i can
get a little
a larger view of it um
um
there's so much yeah okay
oh yeah there we go
perfect
beautiful
all right
okay so you're in c4d you have your
character rig holy crap
what oh my god
dude this is all
so foreign to me how uh
what what what are you using in c4d to
get these little
little huds for the face like how are
you setting this up
yeah these are all with the uh
using like the the splines that they
have so very you can just use uh all
these circles all these rectangles and
do some text um i made this whole facial
rig um
i'm trying to there we go i made this
whole facial rig two years ago at this
point or at least you know these uh all
these knobs uh and i basically copy and
paste it all between my various
characters so they all have the same rig
um and then i just use a bunch of
espresso
um to sort of rig that all up and make
it make each control line up with
different blend shapes wow
espresso that's a thing that i i
i know so little about but it's so
powerful
yeah espresso i mean i i'm also very uh
inexperienced with it but it can be
crazy good especially when you're trying
to rig a character um but yeah you can
see basically
um with the character rig made if i can
oh wait that's why okay
if i i can now sort of make her smile
make her do a smirk
um whoa
i can then combine these sort of things
to create like these weird looking these
weird just looking uh sort of shapes
here
um
there we go
like whatever whatever i'll need the
character to do um i can easily break it
obviously but
um
but you know if i happen to need any
sort of emotion to be done for the short
it's it's fairly easy to do that and we
also have
various brow controls as well just to
yeah just to just for that sort of thing
so holy crap yep so that's that's the
whole rig there's also just a quick a
quick uh rig for the hands as well
because um i did do motion capture for
this but i found before that doing
motion capture for fingers um does not
work out as well as i'd like it to so i
basically have a bunch of pre-made uh
hand positions like making a fist
or
doing a resting pose or things like that
just in case
um i need to quickly animate something
pretty much
wow
that's insane
okay so
you mentioned
i'll just let you keep going yeah just
keep going this is great
yeah so while this uh loads up all the
textures it's a it's a shame that quit
on me but um
yeah i did i basically then took my
character into her pose and did a whole
rough sketch around her to sort of
figure out what the environment might be
so i got the uh this is where i came up
with the ideas of doing like the carpet
on the ground adding like tape to the
the actual window with the don't touch
on it
and then various uh other other things
just came up in this whole sketching uh
sketching
um session pretty much and that turned
into what we see here which is the final
environment which is is quite it's quite
heavy at this point with all the all the
stuff that's happening
um so
navigating around it can be quite quite
a challenge yeah good luck
yeah but you can see pretty much all
these different uh
all these different lights here actually
i can just yeah there we go all these
different squares they're like kind of
hard to see but you have one that's
pointing up in the corner it's pointing
at the shelf um you have this big square
that's pointing at the wall itself to
sort of highlight that a bit and then of
course surrounding our main character
um
you have basically a billion different
different lights set up
um also you can see here a nice showcase
of how just truly how large um the alien
ended up being
compared to the actual ship itself
which once you zoom the camera out you
can see it's super bare bones outside
the the field of view yeah there's not
even a bed model that i made it's just
literally a blanket and a pillow
because it's just barely in the corner
pretty much
um
yep you can see basically all these
little all these little squares
everywhere highlight different parts of
it these are like these blue things at
the top are to highlight basically out
of rim light to her hat and her hair
um
you have yeah you have some other lights
just outside the ship pointing at her to
highlight the rest of her body and then
you have certain lights that highlight
um
characters the shelves um and then some
other things so it's a whole lot a lot
of stuff everywhere and you can also
just a quick uh thing here you can see i
added uh the i added some of my
previously made characters and you can
see they also have the same exact uh
facial rig set up as my other character
um i just didn't bother to delete them
so they're they can technically do some
emotions but obviously they're not like
a humanoid character so they're a bit
more limited
holy crap and i'm blown away by all of
this um
yeah i mean tell me more please
this is great
uh yeah so yeah so for the animation i
did the motion capture
um
even though it's a it's a fairly simple
sort of uh sort of animation that i do
um
i still wanted to get some of that real
world motion um and so basically put on
all the sensors and then just mime the
motion for basically like four minutes
doing so many takes
and it's very funny to look back on this
because i could look pretty ridiculous
um i look i look very intense when i'm
like shooting at the alien but it can be
it could be a lot of fun just sort of
keep doing it over and over again and
eventually something will work
so i just basically do the exact same
thing so many times um i think i
probably got like 10 takes um
and so once i get that back into cinema
4d i'll pick a take that i that i like
and i end up with basically something
that looks like this
and obviously on top there's a whole lot
of keyframed animation um like there's a
bunch of ik to make your hands stick to
the steering wheel yeah the feet
themselves are also just completely hand
animated by me using ik as well
because i needed to dangle and obviously
i didn't i couldn't do that with like
the chair i was sitting so
um that's just why why that's doing that
and then you can also see a lot of the
the facial animation that wasn't really
seen in the spot itself but that i had
to do anyways just for the reflection in
the window itself
um and then moving i guess moving
through the process uh we also have
i also had the background
and one of the reasons i chose to do
like a space back or a space sci-fi sort
of scene
is that i knew i could
save time by making the background a 2d
uh making it a 2d
um sort of setup as opposed to having to
model out a planet get like volumetrics
for like all the gases and like the sun
like that i knew i could find some great
like stock photos or things i had lying
around
um and basically layer them up photoshop
them into something that looked cool but
didn't detract from the actual uh center
of the screen so you can see i left a
big center area for the alien itself to
sort of hang out in amazing nice all
into after effects and make it add some
parallax to make it just a little bit
more 3d totally so your lights in the
top left and top right those are just
those are that's just photoshop right
photoshop lights
yep um they are not lights
i mean yeah
yeah so they obviously informed
basically uh all the lights i put into
the scene itself so i made sure to light
the alien with a blue light and an
orange light from the from behind uh and
then same with the actual main character
um i would add an orange light off in
the corner just to simulate um the whole
sun environment make sure it's like sort
of all matched together
and are you pulling that pulling the
planet from nasa their free stuff
no i just looked up uh i think i looked
up like uh planet in orbit or something
like that um and i found this like super
high quality thing i don't think it was
nasa but um something and i just did a
quick like skew effect on it to add like
a subtle amount of parallax yeah and
then some turbulent displacement on the
wispy atmosphere itself because
that was something i really liked the
look of and i wanted to make sure to
have something like that as opposed to
the the softer
uh the softer more uh
blurred looking blue atmosphere we're
used to yeah
yeah and then so basically then it just
went to rendering it out so this is the
the raw render that i get out of
redshift uh this whole thing
took about about like 15 hours to render
um but that's on i have multiple gpus
that i render this on so
um it on a single gpu would take
probably far longer than that but
yeah it was no it's not bad at all dude
yeah no but yeah again if this was on a
single one it'd probably be up to
multiple multiple days um
so luckily that didn't happen because it
did come down to the wire to uh get this
submitted i think i got it in like four
hours before um and the final geez
yeah the final uh submission is
basically a frankenstein version of
different renders that i had to redo
over and over again because of various
glitches that happened yep um throughout
yeah it was quite it got quite stressful
like you know you wake up the the month
or the sunday of submitting i see like
oh the glove is like has these weird
like little little baby spikes coming
out of it because like stuff was like
glitching uh and i have to render like
that part of it again for like you know
six hours and hope that it all works out
the second time
um and then yeah the last step pretty
much was uh
we have like some quick uh simple
wireframes
with the
here's one without textures that i just
for fun
um and yeah compositing was not as it
wasn't as extensive as i might usually
do
um basically once i got it into after
effects i realized that there's like
too much detail like it's really like
part of it really detracts from what i'm
trying to look at because i couldn't
really figure out where the focal point
of the shot was
um
uh pretty much so pretty much if you see
this wipe here
the compositing that i did pretty much
involved the background which is i took
out a lot of these stars i lowered the
opacity of a lot of like the planets and
things like that and it became overall
like a lot softer uh and really framed
the space alien in this black void
pretty much as opposed to in the
original render where it's a bit harder
to like sort of spot where everything
might be
yeah i also just added like vignettes
blur the blurred the corners added some
chromatic displacement but tastefully of
course oh god dude
that can
so overdone i didn't even notice it on
yours i didn't even notice it yeah it is
it is truly subtle in the corners you
can like kind of see it on the tv but
um
but yeah i always i always add that but
i make it so very subtle because because
yeah it can be it can be truly overdone
but it does it can help a little bit for
some of the realism
um then yeah i've got some some optical
flares on the nebulas and
a bunch of glows everywhere on the space
alien on the computers all the lights
and then that's pretty much it i did uh
i did sound design over top of that
which you can't see in the actual like
yeah the render that i submitted but
i had a lot of fun just doing that these
crazy space number noises of him like
eating all the candies and it's it's
truly ridiculous but that was a that was
just a lot of fun so it sounds like a
little big planet i don't even played
that game when you get the oh yeah yeah
yeah prize bubbles
like it's such a yeah no it definitely
has some of those vibes for sure yeah
um yeah the canon itself like the sound
design on that um yeah definitely so
many little big planet vibes with that
was basically just like a popping noise
that i did as opposed to like uh your
classic canon or machine gun sound so
so that's a lot of fun to do if you guys
have uh any questions for chris please
uh at me here
in the chat let's get these questions in
i'm sure there's a lot uh i saw one do
you do you plan on making tutorials do
you make tutorials
um
yeah i don't really plan on doing
tutorials at the moment basically the
most i do is after all my projects i'll
do like these breakdowns which are a lot
of fun to do and it's basically it's a
uh just a very quick walkthrough of like
all the stuff i do um but in terms of
like tutorials you know um those are
definitely a bit more involved so
probably not at the moment but i'm
always happy to answer questions on like
either youtube or instagram because
i love to just explain like the whole
the whole process
dude this is like this is incredible
this is
very very special um
let's see people oh people are all so
curious are you on windows or mac like
what's going on here
oh yeah yeah yeah i do so yeah i'd use
parsec um
to actually uh work on my windows
computer but i do not really like
windows that much i find macs to be uh
to be much more user-friendly or at
least they're kind of what i'm used to
so i'll use parsec to basically screen
remote share into my computers which are
like in another part of my house and
then i'll just do all the compositing
all the modeling and things like that on
my mac crazy but you know yeah but max
you know they don't really have the gpus
to do like redshift rendering and things
like that these days so
you know that's uh that's sort of why i
do that
okay got you got you
um let's see
uh what's your okay so what's your main
takeaway from this project um what do
you feel that you you walked away with
on this one besides winning all the
prizes and everything and i'll see you
at camp mograph later this year um
besides all that stuff
um i would say i at least a good bit of
advice that like i sort of learned on
this project and like the previous
projects i've done um is to break
everything up into like these little
chunks and it's really just a
psychological thing that i do
where it where i'll break down these
like much larger projects into smaller
like sort of things i need to complete
and i'll just focus on those and i'm
gonna try to think about like all the
other like random things i gotta do um
so it starts with like okay like because
if i if i basically took this project at
face value i'm like all right i gotta
create like a computer character a
whole rigged humanoid character a
background an alien i gotta create two
versions of that like a small alien or
like a big uh expanded one and then i
have to do all the other stuff on top of
that it just feels super overwhelming
yeah um so i basically um even though
like it's good to you know manage your
time but i'll but in terms of just how i
think of it i'll just be like okay my
only thing i got to do is i gotta finish
this character uh this this humanoid
character that's all i gotta do and then
after that once i think about all the
stuff i have to do it's a bit less
daunting because now i have one thing
checked off pretty much um and that's
how i've done much larger projects like
short films and things like that
um where they can certainly be like
pretty intimidating if you just sort of
take it at face value
so you just focus on one one step at a
time essentially
yeah i mean most people do that but
again it's just a way of like
psychologically sort of framing it in
your mind as opposed to like you know
how you might
manage like a project
absolutely did you ever like that that's
that's something that you know you guys
probably hear me say this but something
that i'm trying to
get better at is time management and
being realistic with the time i have
and and still trying to do the most in
that time you know um
yeah
yeah
it definitely is like it's so tough when
you're when you're doing some of these
3d things because they can be like
there are parts of 3d they're like so
fun to do and then there are parts that
are just like the worst like they are
they can be very like soul sucking to
have to do but um and i it's definitely
a fight for me between like you know
focusing on those fun elements and
having to get to like doing like the
weight painting and rigging and all that
stuff that might be a little more
tedious yeah absolutely
um
random question
what did you do for the ammo coming out
of the gun i noticed it wasn't in your
final render did you just come back
around for like another pass in a
separate project file or something
um yeah so originally the uh
yeah originally i had it as a simulation
where i'd submit all these sort of uh
all the candies and they basically i was
trying so long to get them to go into
the
into the character's mouth um and like
sort of collect there but uh sometimes
cinema 4d either it's physics can just
like not cooperate um so after a while i
just sort of deleted that emitter um and
just decided to do it in compositing
with uh particular so i basically was
rendered out like a still image of the
candy itself and then i just randomize
the color and just spat it out into the
into basically the general area of where
it goes and that's unfortunately like
why um these last candies sort of just
like fade into like oblivion they don't
really go anywhere they just kind of
become small and uh very hard to see as
opposed to bouncing off the alien and
going every which way oh to be honest
they actually it kind of looks like
they're um almost like it's carbonation
that it fizzes out
yeah yes
bubbles bubbles that just kind of like
just yeah they definitely have that sort
of uh that motion on them for sure
but that's crazy okay so
particular or yeah that was trap code
particular but honestly you know it's it
was the it's the most basic of sort of
emitter effects just like spewing out
like an image into one direction in 3d
space so it could be done like sort of
any any of after effects particle stuff
how did you how did you animate the
the uh the alien himself like or itself
uh
oh yeah yeah i mean the alien that's
pretty much a bunch of vibrate tags on
every limb pretty much um so the vibrate
tag in cinema 4d just tells like the
rotation of the limb to just go like
every which way um but i turned it way
down so it's going really slowly pretty
much um
so while there was like some there was
some keyframe animation done to make
sure the alien was in the right spot
when it was getting shot at basically
all the limbs after that even when it's
getting shot or just me telling you all
right for this like five second chunk
you're going to move like really fast
with your limbs um and cinnamon 40 just
kind of randomizes that motion and it
looks pretty good so that's just kind of
how i did that and when it blows up
yeah blowing up was that's why i had to
make two versions of the alien so we had
the standard one
where i basically inflated its face
using a bunch of blend shapes to sort of
uh make it look like it was expanding
like a balloon yeah but then there's a
point after it where you can see it
transitions to a completely different
model um right as it blows up okay okay
and it becomes a yeah it becomes like a
round alien that i just scale up and add
a bit of animation on top of yeah
and so you don't really notice it in the
quick motion and all the lights and all
that stuff but that's how i did that
that's smart i like you dude that's
amazing i'm like how did you
transform one model into this completely
different model and oh it's just two
models and
yeah if i had to do it like a lot slower
it would be just impossible if it had to
be like some sort of like werewolf
transformation into this giant uh round
alien it would have been uh truly
difficult i wouldn't have wanted to do
that
jeez man this is like this is an
absolute masterpiece your workflow is
absurd um super on point
very efficient very effective uh i feel
i feel like
with this challenge
specifically i
like
i feel like all these other renders have
just blown
what i can do out of the water and like
y'all
have gone so far
and i'm just trying to keep up with
y'all at this point because
this is
this is i mean yeah they're just
there were like so many good entries in
this like when i was watching the stream
i was like oh man there's just like no
way i can get in the top five like some
of these like uh some of these great
looking entries like people clearly
spend like so many hours on
man well congrats you got first place
um i'll be seeing you at camp mograph
man that's gonna be awesome have you
you've never been before have you yeah
no this will be uh my first
oh
for everyone watching um
it's the greatest thing ever it's i
think tickets go on sale april 20th
um
and it's in like september i believe
middle of september and we'll just be
chilling on the beach learning from each
other
um going down zip lines
playing hacky sack and uh
you know
going to different different little
conferences and fireside chats
it's gonna be sweet it's like the best
thing ever last year was the greatest
time ever um
but it'll be cool to see you there chris
um congrats again dude yeah i'm so
excited thanks man
absolutely um well hey i'll let you go
thanks for your time
um yeah thanks for having me and uh
best of luck man keep crushing it i'll
see you later this year
all right sounds good peace out brother
later man thanks
see ya
wow holy crap
yo that was
that was insane very very very
inspirational i hope you all learned
something i learned a whole lot of stuff
uh as soon as this stream is over i'm
gonna do the uh weekly challenge winners
we're gonna go over that right here
right before we wrap it up um
and uh
i'll
i'll essentially add all the
tags and the chapters and um all the
artists
info where you can find them as soon as
the stream is up so
um
definitely
definitely look out for that but i hope
you guys
i hope you guys had a good time this was
really fun we're definitely gonna be
doing this for the challenges from from
now on at this point at least top five
um because there's just so much to learn
from everybody and each person has like
their their way of doing it they have a
different approach but we saw a lot of
similarities too at the same time it's
really cool to see that everyone here
was like inspired a lot from video games
which is really cool
and everyone started out with like a
reference and um at least some sort of
sketch to help guide their path
starting with characters that's very
interesting i'm so bad at characters
it's terrifying for me to do but
i think
you know
it really depends on what y'all are
trying to do it depends on what you're
trying to learn
you know if you want to start focusing
on characters if you if you're an
environment artist then you know
maybe knowing a little bit about
characters is a prob probably a good
thing
but if you're trying to be a generalist
then i think knowing about characters is
is an absolute requirement
it is my downside 100
um
so it this really inspired me to to
learn characters i mean maybe to take on
zbrush perhaps or substance painter um
those are two programs that are very
high on my list right now
um
i just can't believe his lighting
chris's lighting
is incredible
and
it just makes me think like man i i
should spend more time on lighting i
gotta spend more time on lighting
because it adds so much
very very very very inspirational
wow
uh let's hop into
the weekly challenge shall we
let's switch on over
all right um soto can you go full screen
for me there so i can see the names here
yeah thanks brother
sweet
all right all right all right let's get
into it really quick shall we
um
let me get all set up here
full screen we got the chat
appreciate y'all shout outs to you guys
papaxo what's up dude thanks for hopping
in
um everybody here who's hung out with me
i really appreciate you guys
um but let's dive into the art here so
we got five winners
to announce uh for this weekly challenge
and
the prompt uh was i believe it was was
cozy
i believe what the prompt was so let's
start it off uh our first winner here is
oren cloud with this
beautiful
render um i love the lighting i love the
darkness of this
um
and it's specifically how the soft light
comes in and just illuminates those
pillows and the
blankets and whatnot your color is
amazing too
you know you've been crushing these last
challenges and i love that green yellow
palette that you have is absolutely
beautiful
i'm a sucker for silhouette stuff dimly
lit silhouettes and you're crushing it
with this man your render quality is
always top-notch
this feels cozy to me obviously because
you got a really nice view it's lit well
you can look out that window chill with
the book that you see on the couch over
there and just kick back
snug up on a pillow there
and enjoy a good book with a great view
so congrats oren cloud for winning this
one man
absolutely beautiful next up
we got our boy ronan
killing it on this challenge look at
this
you're using all these little different
tools and and pieces like the postal
stamp there as a carpet
uh you have acorns as lights little
buttons as art on the wall tiny little
flowers
uh wheat
inside of the little tiny glass there
you modeled all the books jurassic park
is up there
this is wonderful you fleshed out this
world so well
and a great little character too
i would love to be chilling up in this
thing
and there's a little ladder that goes
down on the right too that's freaking
amazing
heck yeah ronin congratulations
um
you know since you're a moderator
uh
you know you're definitely eligible to
win these things of course you are it
just comes down to the art who cares if
you're a mod or not it just comes down
to the art and you showed that
you freaking deserve it this is my
favorite one for uh
you know for this for this challenge
here
but you can give that challenge winner
roll uh to one of the honorable mentions
that we'll get into here in just a
minute and all the winners 15 points to
you by the way um towards your rank on
the discord server we got tiers
and y'all will level up throughout the
months throughout the years here
and get some really cool badges on
discord
so next up we have under
with an absolutely beautiful
little setup here i love this so much
your attention to detail is incredible
your lighting is incredible you really
really captured this vibe i remember
when i visited ireland and we had a spot
in dublin
uh they had a little rooftop chill spot
that felt exactly like this and there
was a cat just right in the top of the
frame there was a cat as well
it was a little outdoor spot with a
bunch of plants
the light was filtered through the
through the leaves and whatnot and we
had breakfast up there we met a couple
um who was chilling pretty much just
like this
it was incredible and this brought me
right back to that moment you know this
is very personal obviously what's cozy
to me may not be cozy to y'all
but this one really really spoke to me
it was beautifully lit beautifully
rendered um
so congrats to you under
for winning
the challenge this week next up we have
vasey with this
incredible render and it's a twofer it's
like
you know i love i i am a sucker
for cottages with a bunch of foliage on
a bunch of ivy climbing up these things
it's very reminiscent of like kiki's
delivery service
really good ghibli movie
um you have these very romantic
environments and this totally brought me
to that spot going to grandma's house
chilling making some apple pie the night
version to me is my favorite it
definitely feels mega cozy i can't wait
for this night to get up in there and
have some apple pie and chill out by the
fire and uh
relax after a long day of you know
chopping heads i don't know i don't know
um
yeah vasey this is incredible i can't
wait to see more of your work
congratulations for winning
top five
on the weekly challenge this week and
finally
we got our boy yeah cg md
when he's not saving lives
as a medical doctor
he's doing sick renders
and this one this one really spoke to me
i will uh when it rains usually it's
very rare that it rains in los angeles
but when it does
me and my fiance we turn the lights off
and we go up to the window at the front
of the house
and we grab a blanket and we just look
out onto the street and we see the rain
come down we see the
the street lights
reflecting off of the asphalt uh we see
the the water flowing down
uh by the sidewalk and this totally
reminds me of that um it's a very
peaceful time without phones without tv
without anything just the sound of the
rain
and a loved one
cozied up under a blanket enjoying the
view
so this this took me there
and i love the books man it's all about
the books
what makes books so darn cozy goodness
so congrats to oran cloud ronin under
vasey and yah cgmd for winning the cozy
challenge this week but let's hit up
some honorable mentions because
there's a lot of other pieces of art i
think that did a really cool job so let
me just touch on each one of these
um let's jump into it
all right first up we got
our boy visual
um coming at you with a real cozy render
always crushing it with the render
quality
um
photo realism
i think he does characters in daz
and i love that style you got man you
got a really nice style yeah chilling on
the carpet with the blanket nice
hot cup of tea and a book is classic
cozy very good stuff
uh next up we got velli
i love this so much
ah super cool character
um i this might be the same artist who
did the infinite journeys one on the
train
uh with like these like almost
stop-motion-looking puppets
this is beautiful
i just dig your character i love the
little furs coming out of the blanket
uh classic classic cozy by the fire with
some tea and a blanket very very good
stuff the lovely taco is next
this one to me almost won
i'm gonna be honest with y'all this one
almost won
um
i love the uniqueness of it
i love the shape of it how wacky it is i
love the wide-angle lens the colors are
awesome too
that's a nice little chill spot this
person has
fish in here
and this nice little cottage
beautiful good colors too very very nice
colors
next up we have tapi kiosotaku
with this uh nice little render here i
like what you did you you photo scanned
a tree and then made a scene from it i
love it it's custom
you did it yourself um
it's beautiful very very nice i love
your colors uh personally i would just
love to see a little bit more of that
interior uh it's a little distant for me
it's a little far away i'd love to get
up in there just a little bit more to
see what's going on but i just loved the
rain i love that you used a photo scan
tree and made a little world out of it
it's amazing next up we have scratch
and by the way all of these honorable
mentions you all get five points towards
your rank on the discord server um
so this is super cool i totally thought
this was a photo
but is a render and
you went uh a different direction you
drew the character in and i thought it
was super cool i love that style i would
love to see more of this i'd love to see
a little animated thing
i think that would be awesome so
congrats to you scratch we got one dead
duck
up next
nice little photo reel render here good
character got the cup of tea uh with a
very very
detailed background um that is out of
focus that's like that's a ballsy move
right there
very very good stuff i love the photo
realism super solid
metatrox is next
for honorable mention this spot ah this
is a good spot right here you got the
fire you got the rain in the back i love
your color contrast the orange and the
blue
you really built the scene nicely
i believe it it feels very natural it
feels very real
and that's where i want to be right now
i want to be in a bathtub
right now i think that would be super
solid i should stream from a bathtub
at some point uh that would be
that would be very interesting
uh moving on m design is next
uh i love dude i just love this
environment it's super cool i love the
way you lit it too
i've always wanted to have like pillows
and blankets all over the floor
that to me is like supreme coziness i
love your lighting here i love the the
colors that you're using
yeah you put put together a nice little
short here
showing off all those rugs
that's very nice very very nice wherever
this is i want to be chilling there
we got luco
up next
yeah this is nice
very very uh very detailed
also i like the way that you're choosing
to put all these tungsten warm little
lights and pools of light in the corners
and on specific spots to
highlight the parts that you want the
audience to see you're putting it on the
the poster there on the left it looks
like some sort of poster uh you're
lighting up the background with the
bookcase it's very nice i think you
maybe could go a little bit heavier with
the moonlight coming in i think
would would kind of round it out just a
little bit more
um
but i dig the environment also piano in
the background big fan very good stuff
lab play
what you got going on here this
is a setup that i have
messed around with as a kid
i love forts
gotta love a good fort
and this feels like that to me
having the old tube tv
under the blankets
watching your favorite show
yeah that's a vibe for sure
jack the hack
what you got going on here
a very similar you got the fort chilling
in your pajamas
watching your your favorite desktop
background
uh
eating some oranges
yeah that's a good that's a good time
and i love the color contrast you got
like the orange
and i am color blind it could be blue it
could be purple but it kind of looks
purple
um
yeah dude this is cozy
super cozy
i am the bug
this is cool
yeah i dig your design style here the
render style tune shaders for sure
um
it's very simple you know it might just
be your
your bedroom
but it's lit very nicely
i love that soft glow it's very very
nice
heck yeah
gora becca is next
solid environment my goodness i love
this lighting here coming in at the end
of the day starting to get like uh
golden hour
right when the sun is about to set maybe
an hour 30 minutes before the sun's
about to set
this just made me feel like this kind of
took me back to dublin again where we
were staying no it was actually it was
um
kilkenny i think in ireland we stayed in
this place it was like a four-story
place that was exactly like if you've
seen paddington it was like
that like the paddington house
with the stairs in the middle four
stories
it felt like that and
this one took me back it definitely did
you know someone making breakfast down
on the first floor
you got a t in hand maybe
i love this lighting
photo realism is on point two good stuff
fracture we got you next
yeah this is just this is just a good
time right here i love that lighting
that specific lighting coming from a tv
lighting up a dark room is a vibe
that's a good time
that's what got me on this one
folio
yeah good colors man
love your colors
i love the subject matter too nice
little scientist
stargazer situation but more than just a
stargazer you got
you got some machines and papers and
data everywhere you got
wires and pipes and whatnot but you know
you chilling
reading a book
chomping on a donut
yeah i dig this this is good stuff man
eloy is next
we got a few more this one came darn
close
um i picked winners
that to me like having a character in
the scene
took it over the edge so i think if you
would have had a character in here that
would have maxed it out for me but my
god your colors are incredible your
render quality is incredible your
lighting is incredible
your your
materials
are absolutely insane
yeah this looks beautiful
super solid on the lighting the lighting
and the colors is what gets me on this
one
very nice next is uh vinlan cozy vinlin
yeah we've seen a lot of these we've
seen a lot of these like isometric kind
of renders um
you know i think
they are
uh
we see a lot of them i'll say that we
see a lot of them
however
i really like your lighting here i like
your setup
it seems like it would be a really fun
place to be that bed up top with the
christmas lights that's a vibe for sure
so i wanted to shout you out man good
stuff
cj hash
second to last here but in no particular
order this one is disgusting to be
honest with you
not in a bad way
not in a bad way at all um it's darn
cozy it's super cozy
but it's also disgusting at the same
time
uh it's very well rendered very well
animated i love your colors i love the
concept and i'd love to see more of this
very good stuff and finally the final
honorable mention
is billy
manny
yes
um
this is one of the early renders that i
saw on the discord server uh your color
is nice
you know the scene is nice my favorite
thing about this is
this girl under the floorboards
like not in in a chill way she's under
she's she's hiding under the floorboards
in a chill way and i'm down for it i
love that so much having a little secret
area
like there's nothing chiller than a
chill spot in a secret area
and this
this really got me this one got me
so good stuff to all you guys
congratulations to the five winners
orrin cloud ronin
um
who god dang who else
oren cloud ronin under vasey and yah
cgmd congratul and to all the honorable
mentions congratulations
um this week's challenge i believe soto
correct me if i'm wrong
is uh is huge is that right
yeah so you guys have this week uh on
the discord server the link is in the
description
to check out the weekly challenge and
we're gonna do the live review once a
month when i do live streams but uh
usually throughout the week i'll just
record like a little segment and post it
in the uh
in the winner's channel
on the discord server so you all
have
ranks and badges
attached to your name on the discord
server and the more art you put out you
get a point for participation you get
five points for an honorable mention and
you get 15 points for a win and you get
these really cool like eight-bit badges
kind of like pokemon pokemon uh badges
that level up as you level up as an
artist so it's just a really cool thing
to
to make creating art just a little bit
more fun
uh but y'all wow what a stream that was
a really good time thank you guys so
much for for joining me
i'll take the the last five minutes with
y'all here to do a q a if you guys have
any questions for me just at me here in
the chat um and i'll be hanging out with
y'all
grab some water i hadn't drank i'll
sip of water the whole time my throat is
sore
yes
yes indeed
ronan you gotta think about who you're
gonna give your uh
challenge winner roll to
out of the
the honorable mentions
what you all doing what you all up to
right now
logan is that a window or a light
there's a window
there's a window back here
let's see if i can stop down
oh now it's an auto okay
yeah it's a window it's like it's this
same material
right here
but the sun is just coming down on this
side so it looks like a light
um
have a tub dude i'll have a tub
i'm gonna next stream yo next stream i'm
gonna do it from the bathtub i think i'm
gonna do it uh
let's see
who else
oh william foshe is up in here
yo
what up william
yeah we were talking about how you
stayed up till like four in the morning
to do the judging stream that was like
nearly a five hour stream
with the with the hour tech check before
as well you up for six hours my goodness
dude you're a champ
so good
if you guys don't know william foshee
check out his channel
um it is
spelled william like voucher
f-a-u-c-h-e-r
william foshay
he's got the best unreal engine
tutorials if y'all are trying to get
good
um
what else
how do i personally beat procrastination
um with a cane
uh no
um
you know
that's a good question so i've been
writing a movie
waking up every day
and
spending an hour at least to write
but
uh i was on a good roll i was on a good
good roll until i
went to yosemite for my bachelor party
and then came back the next it was a
week-long bachelor party came back the
next week had my parents in town my
fiance's parents in town
and didn't have any time to write and
then now that all that is back to normal
i'm having trouble
stepping back into writing
and
like i'm just tired i'm tired you know i
want to just rest i want to sleep in
um but i feel guilt from not writing
i know i should be
so what do i need to do honestly i just
need to sit down and write
it's a big priority of mine um
i think
procrastination happens to all of us and
i think the better reason we have
to do
what we're trying to do
the more we'll actually
do the thing right so if you just want
to like learn a new language just
because of it
then that might not be a strong enough
reason but if you want to learn a new
language
in order to
um
connect with your
wife's parents
when you see them
that's a better reason that's like not
maybe not a better reason it's a
stronger reason
so consider why you're doing it and see
if it's if it's worth doing it and if it
means
if it means a lot to you then i think
if you can think about that
then you know it's an important thing
that you should be doing uh what else
let's see
hypoxia what's up dude great stream
talking about characters i have the
sketchbook in hand and drawing a quick
character every day is a great way to to
discover a style oh i like that i like
that a lot
drawing a character every day is a good
way to discover a style
or a new character perhaps um
you know it could be could be a cool
thing to do in 3d i feel like a sketch
is a lot easier to do when you wake up
go to a coffee shop maybe or just
in your bedroom do a little quick sketch
through i think i think 3d is a little
bit more involved but
i like that i like that it's very nice
let's see um
can you do a segment in the live stream
where you react to every submission and
give suggestion and feedback for
beginners oh man that would take a lot
um
i i
do i don't have the time
um i try and keep it as distilled as
possible you know
um
[Music]
i think doing stuff like this hopefully
helps y'all
um
i
i'll mention a thing or two on the
weekly challenges like i like you all
just saw me do it
granted it usually is just like me
saying the things i like versus the
things that i think could be
constructive criticism
maybe the next time we do a live judging
stream for the next community challenge
whenever that comes along
um
which will be later this year we're
trying we're trying to do two here
uh maybe instead of just good things to
say we we say good things but we also
say a constructive piece of feedback as
well i definitely definitely hear you on
that
um
let's see
hmm
yeah hey you know good stuff just take a
step back when you feel like you're
disconnected with your hobby that's very
good advice um we were talking about
that earlier if you feel like you're not
having fun with your hobby anymore
take a break just take a break from it
it'll come back you know you love it too
much that it'll just disappear like that
ali abbas it was fun watching your
stream while doing calculus greetings
from pakistan i'm glad you're able to
focus on your calculus while watching
this stream
i hope you're having a good time in
pakistan that's awesome that's a part of
the world i've never been to before but
i'm down to travel i love traveling so
maybe one day i'll make it out there
andra can i talk about my infinite
journey surrender
um
sure
let me just take a few minutes
let's see
let me
let me pull this
submission yeah
all right
here we go
boom all right so
this art here
uh i wasn't too happy with it
really
yeah i wasn't too happy with this one uh
it didn't really feel special to me and
maybe i just need to take a break from
it maybe it's fine
um
but
i feel like i spent way too much time
modeling details that wouldn't be seen
i wish i could have had more in the
background
to
communicate the sense of speed
because right now it's just kind of like
camera shake that's doing it
um
yeah i don't know like the character
it's fine i'm looking at it now like
it's fine it's okay
um it's funny that you guys recognize
the helmet too i know nothing about
racing
and you're all like yo that's this
dude's specific helmet that's hilarious
i switched out all the all the logos for
rococo and maxon and infinite journeys
wacom mograph
all that good stuff
um
yeah my halfway through this project i
got really down on
the way it was shaping out you know i
felt that no matter like i set myself up
for the most difficult thing possible
which is just an infinite detail um
of 3d modeling i i i could have been 3d
modeling still to this day
um
because what i set out to do was build a
cockpit scene
in the foreground and the cockpit
that is a very detailed
setup there's a million switches and
knobs and like it would have it would
have taken me months and months and
months to do this thing justice
i wanted to have more wires um and
circuitry hanging around i wanted to
have more
dangly bits like
uh
being
affected by the g-forces
um
there was a lot that i just couldn't do
and i had to kind of cut it off at the
end because i ran out of time
and it all came down to time management
i
and the idea perhaps you know i i talked
about
how in my mind i had a month plus i had
a month and two weeks because
technically i didn't need to
come in at the finish line
because as long as this was done for the
top 100 montage i had i had six weeks so
i had 45 days but no i didn't really
have 45 days because i'm not working on
the weekends
um
you know i had like half that
essentially especially since i was
taking time uh taking half days to work
on the art i wasn't doing a full eight
hour day on this
so i only had like a third or a quarter
of the time i set out
i originally thought i had
and my idea was so darn ambitious
it was probably
a a true 45 day eight hours per day
idea and i didn't have that so i bit off
way more than i can chew i
underestimated the amount of work that
would go into this i under i
underestimated the amount of days i
really had
and
you know some of you guys might be
looking at this be like dude this looks
great what are you even talking about um
but
for this is just me personally it's all
personal right um
i wanted to do so much more with it
so i learned so much just from
from coming through this feeling like i
failed um
knowing that in the future
i need to be a little
less
ambitious and give myself room to
breathe
i wanted to do a lot more compositing on
this too and have a lot more depth in
the scene
and i was also doing a lot of details
and spending time on things that weren't
seen you know like the
scratches i i spent a whole stream
texturing that monitor on the right
for like four hours
and honestly that's just
a basic material i didn't need to do any
surface imperfections on that thing
the only surface imperfections you can
see is like on the race chair
on the left
the window for sure which is like the
easiest thing and then maybe on
the materials on the bottom by the
shifter
uh little piece
but yeah i just felt like it could have
used a lot more detail that i didn't
have time for
um
but i don't know all in hindsight
the video i'm putting together breaking
down the scene i go into everything i go
into uh everything i'm talking about and
more i get into how i specifically
modeled it
uh different tools that i used all while
kind of like
reflecting on the things i think i could
have done better with
uh and and it ends in a positive way
absolutely ends in a positive way
because i would rather have gone through
this and know like it's about time it's
about time i
i start taking on a little bit less
and
maximizing
that a simpler scene i i want to
maximize a simpler scene as opposed to
coming in under the like under the
finish line on an insanely
ambitious scene if you guys know
cornelius domrick
he is an absolutely incredible 3d artist
i believe he uses c4d and octane
and um his he's very well known for his
incredible amount of detail
and he did a piece of art um it was like
the mars 2048 whatever
uh piece of art with like the astronaut
looking up at uh like a wall
and it's during the day lit during the
day it's like blue orange there's a
little robot on the right of like a
sci-fi city
and i think that took him eight months
you know i love his art because of his
it is so detailed but
i don't i don't have eight months to do
one thing or at least for that challenge
you know
so
[Music]
i'm learning a lot guys i'm learning a
lot
[Music]
all the time
so
i appreciate you guys thank you for uh
for listening to me there
look out for this breakdown it's gonna
be two weeks on the 16th saturday the
16th um lots to learn on that breakdown
for y'all
so
mark your calendars
thank you guys
um
i think it's about time to call it i
don't know uh
got anything else here
i appreciate you guys
thank you so much for
sticking with me for learning with me
learning and growing together
and
i will see y'all
two weeks from now pre-edited video
breakdown for my infinite journeys scene
all the things i learned how i'm gonna
do things better in the future so y'all
take care of yourselves i'll see you on
the discord server and have a good one
peace out later guys
[Music]
and
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
hey